[Music]
thank you
foreign foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
irrigation there we go the Avalanche
continues
[Music]
there's a big threat on the board
is furious it's going straight for the
kill Wesley so has blundered he's
blundered his Knights white king is
trapped this is
Carlson showing his genius
I'm so excited to spend my birthday here
together with you guys our excellent uh
chess experts in the studio Grandmaster
David Howell International Master Tanya
Foxton and Grandmaster Robert has and oh
Robert yesterday what a day especially
winners final with Magnus Carlsen and
Hikaru Nakamura what did you take away
from that it was epic and it was mind
game some tricks by Magnus Carlsen he
seemed to be in Hikaru nakamura's head
that bid one second apart that was
fantastic yeah and today Tanya it's all
about getting that second spot in
tomorrow's Grand Final to meet Magnus
Carlsen who do you think will take that
final spot it is going to be a tough
match for both these players now Wesley
against Arjun is what we start with of
course on paper it's easy to say that
Wesley is a favorite but do not
underestimate Arjun he has shown that on
a good day he can beat the very best
players he has been informed the only
one so far in this event to have beaten
Magnus Carlsen uh and I think he has
played phenomenally well so far he needs
to come in again with that same
Precision try and get Wesley in messy
situations create a Chaos on the board
because if it's a strategic positional
fight
can't imagine a player like Wesley going
down in that so Arjun needs to do what
he does best and take it up a notch wow
oh that's going to be interesting and
yesterday David we had a lot of fun as
well are you getting a lot of messages
about Pokemon that's all I'm getting the
inbox was full this morning Kaya but uh
yeah go team Pikachu yeah that's your
favorite uh Snorlax
well Magnus Carlsen he has a day off
today actually because he's already
ready for the Grand Final and Magnus
he's in Canada visiting the chess brass
he did post a picture on Instagram
simply doing what I enjoy and enjoying
myself and Tanya do you think this is
just what Magnus likes the most in the
sports club playing chess being with
friends he loves it having a good time
playing chess that is life goals and
Magnus having a good time there and
that's when he plays his best chess as
well is that showing David that Magnus
is actually really enjoying himself now
it really is he's not necessarily
hitting his highest levels but he's
doing enough and you can see on the
board he's very relaxed he's not putting
too much pressure on himself and
especially in these long online
tournaments where it's a real grind it's
a real psychological battle not just
with your opponents but also with
yourself uh yeah he's somehow getting
the results he needs he definitely is
and today it's all about getting that
final spot in tomorrow's Grand Final
yesterday we had some epic battles one
of of them was between the two young
Indians Arjun aragaisy and yukesh
this is his final shot yeah
King's F1
sling is legal in Chester I think his
idea is to keep the Rook on the h-file
to attack he's just telling origin you
are not castling and if you do I am
going to attack your king wow any of
those options
what is this move Bishop takes Rook it
takes Bishop it's brilliant it's over
good cash is knocked out of the
tournament Arjun Eric icy makes it
through oh there we go it started this
is the Winner's final it goes for the
more ambitious approach wow that is
making intentions very clear shots fired
very surprised I've got to say that
Hikaru looks so Poker Face on the camera
because I would be terrified here for
black how do you get that white porn it
must be so frustrating Hikaru knows he's
about to make a draw and finally we see
it wow here we go look at Magnus he
quickly responds with Knight F6
challenging that Rook on its place and
now that Rook is really oddly placed are
we gonna see a repetition again are we
gonna see Bishop B3 Queen F5 Bishop C2
it is happening we are heading
yay we've got liftoff
yes because there's a tactic Knight upon
an E5 that is a game changer oh he
doesn't find it he moves his Knight away
look at the evaluation bar dropping down
in Black's favor those are two Runners
and Hikaru is he gonna try and flag
Magnus the answer is no it's a draw hey
Cara is actually the one who offered a
draw that's the ultimate sign of respect
that is a good show of sports and shirt
Magnus Carlson wins the winner finals
with a draw
a smile on Magnus Carlson's face and
also in the studio to guide us through
this day for in the air things Master is
international Master Ivanka and he did
seem happy yesterday winning that match
against Hikaru but Banks actually said
in an interview that uh he wasn't too
happy with the way they both played the
winner I mean he he basically said that
you know he struggled actually at
finding a few resources you know he even
said that there was a resource that he
should never ever missed in a million
years and he actually said that the best
ever best move in that match was
actually predicting the time for the
Armageddon he's going to call it a soul
read and of course Magnus bidding 8
minutes 58 Hikaru bidding 8 minutes 59.
it's a big battle to get the black
pieces in Armageddon and uh well Hikaru
definitely he will have to wait because
he has to meet today's Victor over
where's the Wesley so and Arjun eragaisy
yep hikara Nakamura is playing later
today we also had a loser's bracket
yesterday and we can take a look at the
results on
the losers bracket the first it was a
loser's Port finals Arjun Eric icy
knocked out go cash that was an intense
battle they played some fantastic games
these two youngsters yeah and I really
like the way that Arjun aragaisy
actually approached that you know he
came very well prepared and he decided
just to take it into some kind of messy
position where gakash just couldn't
navigate the complications so he looked
very strong and Wesley so just looked
powerful I mean he's been unbeaten in
this tournament he was also unbeaten
when he won the title Tuesdays twice
actually something that only Hikaru
Nakamura has done wow and yeah I have to
say Wesley looking very impressive and I
agree with what Tanya said earlier Arjun
really has to follow in his role models
footsteps that's Gary Kasparov and try
to mix it up come with some fighting
spirit and aggression yeah Magnus
Carlsen has actually lost a game in the
air things Master to our generic icy he
is ready for the Grand Final Hikaru and
Wesley playing now on the losers bracket
they haven't lost the game yet no they
haven't noticed yet it seems a bit
unfair actually but such are the rules
of Armageddon chess and uh where a draw
is insufficient if you're playing with
the white pieces yeah
We are following
um division one today but there is also
division two and division three going on
in the air things monsters and these are
today's uh games coming up in division
two there's a winners final with
two fantastic players Fabiano caruana is
fighting today what do you expect from
the winners finally here Ivanka this is
going to be a very interesting battle
because actually traditionally Fabi
hasn't actually been very good at speed
chess but he has been working on that in
recent years and then we have you Yang
Yi who has a very creative style and
actually if you were to look at their
head to head it's actually you Yang Yi
who has the better of him Fabiano and we
also noticed another big name in
division two still in their fighting
former world champion Vladimir kramnik
edible I know I mean I I he's like my
personal favorite you know it's so great
to have a former world champion fighting
and there's also someone who is slightly
older than their counterparts you know
it really is great to have such a role
model playing and doing so well but you
know he does have a tough path ahead of
him this is not the final step he has
three matches to go he has to win three
in order to get to the Grand Final
that's a big ass yeah
but division three will be decided today
actually the Grand Final is coming up
today and it is between these two Sam
Savion against pragna number what you
expect
it would actually feel like Groundhog
Day for these two because I actually
played them each other in the winners
bracket it was Sam Sabian who won in
this hundred move Armageddon it was that
close and of course he knocked down
pregnant down it kind of felt like a
game of snakes and ladders there and
Prague had to work his way back up there
and it's going to be tense it's going to
be very very close Sam Sabian starts off
with the white pieces and that's very
critical in these two matching counters
yeah let's take a look at what they are
fighting for this is the price Fund in
the air things Masters a total of 235
000 in all three divisions and remember
the winner of division two not only gets
ten thousand dollars and 50 tour points
the winner also qualifies for the next
first division event in the Champions
chess tour
and uh
we're gonna follow from the start here
division one is going to be the losers
semi-final coming up Wesley so is
fighting to go all the way to the losers
final to meet Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley
so
he has some big goals coming up in 2023
your top three goals that you hope to
achieve in 2023 let's see the first one
would be to qualify to the candidates
I've only played in the candidates once
and it didn't go very well in 2018
so I'm very excited to see what 2023
holds uh there'll be some over the board
tournaments here and there but almost
have to determines are held online and
they're very important they got a lot of
stakes I'm very pleased to win last year
the global chess tournament I'm excited
to be part of the new championships
during chess.com it interesting thing
with this new partnership will will hold
for them win some big online tournaments
that would be very nice for me as a
player I'm trying to balance myself
between being very good at classical
while also doing that bad online and
speeches because they're two they're
very different things and so this year
is going to be exciting as well as a
challenge and my calendar is actually
getting very full at the moment I also
need time to spend between resting or
covering and also preparing and number
three would be
too ambitious but no it's a
reach the top three
some impressive goal
let's go right now is to reach the
loser's final to face the car Nakamura
he's up against Arjun aragaisy and
the player that wins this match between
Wesley and Arjun the player that reaches
the losers final is actually guaranteed
a spot in the next first division event
in the air things monster do you think
that's something that is maybe
especially for Wesley in the back of his
head heading into this match yeah I
think for Wesley so he was given
automatic entry into this one he wants
to earn himself a chance once more and
he sees this as an opportunity to face
off against the car Nakamura he wants
that rematch I think Wesley he's trying
to earn his place in that Grand Final
yeah who do you hold as a favorite in
this match David well I'm gonna have to
go with experience I'm gonna have to say
Wesley so even though I am arjun's
biggest fan as I said yesterday not many
people have crushed me my imaginary guys
he has crushed me I think it's going to
be very close there's a lot at stake
that first division spot for the next
tournament but whoever wins is gonna
have to run the gauntlet anyway imagine
facing Hikaru next then having to face
Magnus in the final and having to beat
Magnus twice whoever gets there uh the
Herculean task yeah it's best out of two
games in the losers semi-final if they
are tied after those two games then it
will go to Armageddon and Wesley and
arjunler sitting basically on opposite
sides of the world it's quite early in
the morning for Wesley so in Minnesota
Arjun late at night playing in India and
what will it take for Arjun today Tanya
to beat Wesley and make it to the losers
final he has to have a lot of energy for
today's match now Wesley is perhaps the
hottest player on the circuit to beat he
is super duper solid and I'm a big fan
of Wesley I mean how can you not be the
guy he's just probably one of the
kindest chess players and on the Beast
he's just I mean on the board he's an
absolute Beast he just doesn't lose any
games
again what I said earlier Kaya it's
really important for Arjun to stick to
his style today he needs to get those
Dynamic positions the kind which is just
filled with landmines you know everyone
and anyone can go wrong and that's why
he has his best chance against uh Wesley
he needs to believe that he can beat him
they played together at the top of Steel
chess India wrap it in Blitz and in fact
Arjun with the white pieces did get a
win against Wesley in the blitz section
and the other two games were to draw so
in speed chess I think he does have that
confidence that he can do it that said
it's so hard to bet against someone like
Wesley yeah definitely
10 years separate these two players
Wesley so playing for the US and Arjun
airgasi playing for India ranked at
number eight and 38 in the world in
classical chess and Wesley we call him
so solid all the time Robert Arjun we've
seen him sacrifice pieces is there just
two very different styles up against
each other here completely different
styles clashing today because Wesley so
in the last classical event he says he
wants to focus on his classical chess he
had two wins and nine draws our generic
geissi played more Fighting Chess
throughout the Tata steel Masters he end
up with five losses and no wins to his
name it was a bad event he could put
that in the past but Arjun he's
typically very combative Wesley he wants
to keep things nice and steady okay and
he starts off with the white pieces
Wesley so best out of two rapid games if
they are tied it will be decided in
Armageddon the time control is 15
minutes plus three seconds increment and
we have started we have liftoff it's a
King's Pawn opening Wesley has gone
through the Italian game several times
over ready this tournament including
twice against Hikaru Nakamura didn't
lead him anywhere we've got to say he's
also doubled with the Spanish with which
opening will he choose slightly ought to
see him pause there but just finding his
bearings and there we go it's the
Spanish maybe not predicting E5 from
Arjun today Arjun does play every
opening imaginable uh solid start to
this one yeah Wesley's gone for the
Spanish and of course Arjun was prepared
for this
I think it is an advantage to Wesley to
start with the white pieces uh with two
games and the reason for that is of
course because he has the higher seating
in the tournament but in a two-game
match imagine starting with the white
pieces if you're able to create your
chances and get that win Arjun just has
one more game to strike back and he
plays with black tattoo so that is a
really difficult spot to be in Arjun
needs to make sure that things don't go
too wrong in this one he has to
neutralize that edge because a player
like Wesley you give him one opportunity
you know he doesn't maybe go for the
most dynamic options on the board but
he's that player who makes the most of a
mistake that the opponent does so if
Arjun slips even slightly today Wesley
will grab it with both hands and not
give Arjun a chance this is a super
important game because I think for Arjun
starting with black he has to be really
careful in this one and it's just really
really focused the whole day he cannot
let his mind go anywhere
absolutely Kaya uh but I you know we
look at Arjun on the camera and it
almost appears that as if he's just
gotten out of bed he's got that classic
I don't care Arjun pose going on yeah
but let me tell you that is just
deceptive the guy is super focused right
now he knows that he needs to get this
job done to play that match against
Hikaru and he knows he's up against one
of the finest in the world they're kind
of they kind of look uh the same the way
they're sitting right is this a very
typical chess player pose just leaning
yeah supporting the big brains that they
both have and just before the game we
saw Arjun checking the air quality maybe
checking the aircon but uh I want to
praise his hair quality in this game
like uh like Tanya said uh yeah just got
out of bed look just looking really
chilled out and uh that has brought him
luck so far but uh meanwhile it's a
variation we call the anti-martial uh
where white doesn't allow a Gambit that
we saw yesterday between uh Hikaru
Nakamura and Magnus Carlsen and instead
a set of Bishops are off the board black
does have a set of double pawns uh in
the center on the e-file but other than
that everything else looks balance
Robert and I always like to say when
there are double pawns it means they're
open files and that Rook The castled
Rook it is open along the f file that
could spell some trouble for the white
king at some point but right now west is
keeping the position locked up zero
pawns have been traded it's becoming a
strategic battle in the early stages but
white really would like to do is trade
those Queens if you could pluck them off
the board we get into a queenless middle
game where White's Pawn structure nice
and healthy and blacks contracts are a
little bit compromised so it's a long
battle that we're about to see take fold
yep a long battle and we will see these
slightly mysterious Maneuvers such as
arjun's last move just shuffling that
Rook across maybe hinting that that Rook
will jump down the board later on to go
for White's lone a pawn uh that a pawn
is an intruder in the black camp and uh
could be a real weakness later but first
Wesley breaks in the center he's not
happy to just sit around and wait he uh
asks questions of arjun's Center those
that massive black porns there and after
black reacts defending holding
everything together he does develop his
Queen so a clear threat on the board for
the first time really in this game
White's Queen is eyeing up a Target that
black apron so on the diagonal
threats how does Arjun Parry this one
well as you're pointing out one of the
ideas that black has is to step up with
The Rook all the way to B5 and that's
the point of getting the Rook to this
while seemingly blocked file you really
want to Target that weakness on A5 which
has shifted so far away from the
friendly B Pawn on B2 now that's one way
that you can defend the S6 and put
pressure the other idea that black has
in these kind of positions David is with
the last knight move the retreating
right night move it might look passive
but it's only retreated to go forward
eventually you can already gobble up on
D4 which I see is what arjun's gone for
and after all the trades in the center
that Knight on D7 will in fact jump up
on the board over to C5 got that A6 pawn
and put pressure on the E4 Bond I like
how arjuns handle the opening so far
yeah uh again a profit both of you in
this tournament you're predicting the
future really really well this has
happened and Arjun does have a very nice
night here holding everything together
Wesley meanwhile needs to get these
start working and black has more Central
points there's one tactical note and the
reason why origen played this line is
that Wesley his last move was Knight
takes Pawn on D4 he had the option of
taking the A6 Pawn if we just go back a
turnier but that would have allowed a
potentially devastating exchange
sacrifice Rook takes Knight on F3
exposing the white king there are not
many Defenders on that flank so for that
outside pass Pawn that white has on A5
that looks great the king is in some
serious danger of the queen and the
Knight ready to hop in and attack the
white king and this is not Wesley so
style he wants things to be safe for his
King rather than playing his
double-edged game yeah so he definitely
took the safety first approach there and
we're expecting to continue doing that
but it's not necessarily obvious what
white should be doing now uh one move
for example would be just solidifying
this Pawn chain just keeping everything
nice and controlled next move bringing
the bishop out but it's nothing to worry
about for Arjun it's nothing to be
scared of it it just feels like a very
balanced position and I do love the
flexibility of Black's Bishop for
example about to appear on the long
diagonal Black's Queen can choose to go
on either side of the board maybe
towards that white king later on it it's
uh yeah balanced position early days
these kind of middle games are so much
to do with Bond structures and that's
where really the whole focus is on and
it's mostly on the queen side there are
two weaknesses for each of these players
for white it's that pawn on A5 which
might look like an aggressive Pawn but
actually it can often come under
pressure the other one of course the one
right below the A6 Pawn which was Under
Fire and we see both players uh know
that well Archer kind of got out of the
opening neutralizing White's Edge and
looks pretty calm so far
Wesley there shifting a little bit David
what's your chest pose
what would you what would be your chest
pose uh my chest pose sir Tanya oh I
don't know just
not really it's more like these two just
uh heading hands hiding from the world I
feel like we can pull up that chest pose
you know if the producers back there a
certain photo that's been happening uh
with a gold medal around his neck and a
shirt off his body so I feel like that's
your ultimate chest pose that's true
yeah you caught me out on that one I
wonder if it's allowed to turn up like
uh like that to a chessboard
I'm gonna try it well there was a lot of
talk about dress code in the rapid and
Blitz World Championship right uh Magnus
was it that showed up and
not I guess they call it appropriate
clothing because it wasn't like shirt or
suit what was the problem I think he was
wearing a puma hoodie there and it was
the day that he showed up really late
for his game and game running I think it
was a Blitz game you've got three
minutes on the on the clock the guy just
runs in with 30 seconds left two and a
half minutes late uh and uh yeah Freda
does have a very strict dress code for
their official championships they do
tend to give out warnings first before
they take Serious action but Danielle
just seeing Magnus run with his hoodie
on and then go on to win in just 30
seconds that was insane so tell me he's
running he's wearing Puma gear and he's
winning a game with minimal time so that
sounds like a hashtag ad and maybe
that's why he got the warning you know
they kind of hit you on the wrist for
that one I bet Puma was very happy I
also remember from Fisher random World
Championship
got told off also for no uh dressing
appropriately I think is what they said
they're such Rebels
they're all doing it for the memes
that's for sure yeah and that's uh
what's so nice about online chess as
well they can basically wear whatever
they want so the question from David is
can they be shirtless
I don't want fide writing into me you
know giving me a warning already I'm not
actually going to do it but how cool
would it be okay so let's say you're
wearing your shirt but you turn up to
your next over the board event just
wearing your gold medals
uh anyway
Wesley says in the tank he's been
thinking for around three four minutes
now
uh a long time and Tanya I wanted to ask
you actually the previous days but now
feels like the perfect moment Archer and
Eric I see this massive sponsorship deal
uh record-breaking I believe oh how much
do you think it's going to help him a
lot I think this is exactly what's
required to step it up and go to the
next level of course all these
youngsters their ultimate dream is to
fight for the world championship match
and we've seen with Arjun he's had such
a breakout performance over the last two
years a meteoric rise really just came
out with a boom out of the pandemic and
you know Crossing 2700 being one of the
top rapid players in the world to some
star-started tournaments he played and
really marked his own over there
established himself with the elite and
then it is about being super strong to
really taking up taking it up that Notch
and for that you need that financial
support and I think that money is going
to be put into some good use some good
training I know they've mixed it up with
the trainers and sort of um arjuns
getting help from some of the best in
the world now with that so it's going to
go a long way in his dream of becoming a
world champion one day yeah I believe it
was around 1.5 dollars that's incredible
and it was a single Singaporean company
I'm half Singaporean you know where's
the money
but it's an action yeah it's with Arjun
and he deserves it he's uh he's been so
great and do you think this could be
start the start of a new trend for
younger players uh you know each having
their individual sponsors
I actually think the champion Chester
has played a huge role in that I mean we
saw the entire explosion happen with
that Prague big win I think it was in
the Athens Masters yeah it was the first
time in 2022 February it was yeah yeah
it's basically one year ago exactly a
year ago and chess exploded in India we
had our prime minister tweeting about it
we had Sachin Tendulkar tweeting about
it and that's when it got into this big
mainstream news and of course with their
performances backed by that because
that's really where it's at uh people
have been taking notice of these young
talents and the support has been coming
in and I think that's what's required in
our spot to make that next jump for this
new wave this wave of these teenagers
yeah to really shake up the elite in the
world absolutely that you can actually
make a living of Chess from an early age
absolutely and I think this money the
sponsorship money it just goes into your
training and to step up to that very
next level because this jump from 2700
to fighting for the world championship
is is way bigger than it seems and I
think it's the hardest one to make yeah
yeah it gets incrementally harder right
the higher you go up the rating ladder
the harder it is to make those uh those
gains and uh yeah we've seen plenty of
people try to challenge Magnus but not
quite kind of stay at that 2800 level
consistently like he can and even in
India we've had Visions but we haven't
had another Wishy on it since him uh so
much darling so many youngsters and I
think this is the generations that's
going to change that yeah we know chess
is booming in India what would you say
is the state of Chess in the U.S Robert
it's kind of complicated question
because the U.S has been criticized in
recent years for bringing in Talent from
around the globe levonne Ronin is now
playing for the U.S Federation in recent
years Wesley so is one of the players
and of course we welcome them with open
arms uh but at the younger levels it's
kind of the Grassroots levels chess is
booming in the U.S and many more people
are playing the game I think people too
often focus on the top players don't see
everyone that's working up the youngest
Grandmaster in chess history I'll be
monumentra from the United States
Christopher you who like gukesh has
composed puzzles and is a strong
Grandmaster in his teenage years from
the United States so we are seeing many
strong talents including Sam sevian who
is in the third division uh Grand Final
right now so there is a lot going for
the us but I think people like to
compare to the top of the world and
fabina carwana Hikaru Nakamura like
where's that next player coming from
it's really really difficult to get
there yeah
must be a name that you know could be a
potential next world champion at some
point one of the youngest Grand Master
in chess history I think there's a lot
of pressure on you and of course there
are others as well like Tani I mean his
story is very famous uh in a book and I
believe it's going to be in into a movie
so there's so many talented players
around the globe and we're just treated
to see them play yeah yeah we had Tony
on the show last year what a cool guy uh
definitely a big chess Talent now in
this one a bunch of moves on the board
what's happening yeah a bunch of Trades
we did see a couple of minor pieces
leave the board the pawn structure is
almost the same as it was when we last
talked about the game but black has
fixed things in the center lock things
down and it's this bishop versus knight
scenario and uh of course we were
talking in previous days about it being
a matter of style it being a matter of
taste but with this Pawn structure it
definitely feels like the Knight holds
its own against the bishop white does
have the opportunity to try and trade
off later on capture that black knight
but that doesn't lead to any advantage
with the extra Central pawns for black
with the extra central control it
definitely feels like the more pieces
come off the board the happier Argent
will be right now and big decision I
don't think you should rush to trade
Queens we should mention here Robert but
uh what else could Archer be thinking
about I just think it was a brilliant
last move from Wesley so because so many
people would say I can't allow you to
take my queen and double isolate my
pawns but if black does grab the queen
right now would be a huge mistake
because Pawn structure Daniel let's say
it's overrated people look at the
Aesthetics after the capture The Rook is
forced back and then white can in fact
take this Knight on C5 once The Rook
Retreats because the open D file is so
important in particular the D5 square
that Rook hits two pawns at the same
time there's no way for black to defend
them White's just going to go upon
grabbing it's going to be happy pickings
for uh Wesley so there's no way our
generic guys he is trading Queens
despite how bad the white Pawn structure
would look yep it would look terrible
but you win a pawn in the process uh at
the very minimum so Ultron here he was
he will for sure be looking in a
different direction does he just
maintain the status quo I guess you can
move this Rook I'm not sure where you
want to place it this night at some
point you can just Retreat it back to a
safe Square this Rook is a bit stuck I
love this piece just a few moves ago but
suddenly now it's tied down as a
defensive piece holding and protecting
its own night it's never really going to
be able to gobble up this Pawn which is
well defended by white truck so this
Rook does look like a clumsy piece
normally Rooks you want them shifting
across the board on open lines here it's
just very locked in so I don't like that
piece at all for Arjun but the rest of
his position very solid I don't see any
specific threats for white uh if black
just takes the time out just as an
example pushes a pawn I don't see what
Wesley's doing next maybe it is this
idea that Robert mentioned of lifting
The Rook but that also looks clumsy in
its own right there would be some
tactics there potentially and both sides
having loose pieces so I do expect Arjun
to play the waiting game just a very
slow move here but it's not necessarily
his style it's not what he likes to do
he's going to be trying to calculate and
solve problems that way but arjun's
style is to be more aggressive but if he
tries to do that in this position by
going after that week a pawn with the
Knight falling back to B7 yes it looks
as if that a pawn is undefendable and
you're going to end up losing it but
actually this would be a huge mistake
because now the White Queen gets so
active David you go Queen to C6 and
you're hitting that A6 pawn and this is
a trade that is going to result in
White's favor because take a look at
this if you capture the a pawn with the
Knight
Queen takes A6 hits The Rook hits the
Knight and you actually end up losing a
lot of material so right now you need to
play it a little slowly like you're
saying makeup on move make a rook move
and I like this because now what he's
done is he's defended that A6 spawn he's
threatening to go back with the Knight
to B7 the idea that I was just
discussing and if the queen moves
forward then at least the A6 Pawn is
defended yeah that's what we call
prophylaxis in chests such as defending
against threats that haven't yet
appeared on the board and uh he's just
covering his weak pawns covering any
potential threats for white so really
nice classy move there from Arjun it did
cost him a bit of time and now the
players are roughly balanced on the
clock
the Queens are eyeing up each other what
what is your tip for
for you know uh beginners in chess uh in
a position like this do you want to keep
the Queens on the board you want to get
rid of them what is the best type it's
always going to be situation dependent
but in terms of this position in
particular uh the queen trade if white
captures black queen it welcomes the
black king towards the center in the end
game that's very important and from
Black's point of view you want to take
the queen to ruin White's Pawn structure
but we were talking about those lines
where the white Rook gets too active
after a series of Trades so you
typically would say to keep the tension
until you're entirely ready to release
it and this is a great example that
neither side really wants to budge and I
think we're going to see Wesley play a
move with a pawn over on the king side
likely his F2 Pawn up to F3 just to
create a pawn chain and defend his Pawn
the tension is going to remain here it's
not always easy to give a kind of a
blueprint of what to do when Queens are
staring at each other yeah I have a very
young student and uh okay there we go
Robert predicting the move correctly and
uh this young student her instinct is to
trade pieces anytime There's an
opportunity she'll make the trade she
doesn't even think just because she
assumed that the end game will be
simpler easier to understand but the
thing is you have to trade on your own
terms you have to make sure you don't
give your opponent two or three Tempo uh
Tempe there for example if white does go
and trade off and allow the black king
into the center that only improves the
black position if black trades off you
improve the white position so you have
to make sure it's on your own terms you
don't rush and you don't worsen your
position in the meantime and there we go
Tanya you uh yeah you have your profit
hat on again predicting this night
Retreat you know I liked it at first but
while you were just talking about this
great advice about trading on your terms
I got a little worried about it because
yes you're hitting A5 and once white
moves the queen to C6 the A6 spawn would
be attacked but I thought the Rook was
hanging but instead Westie chooses a
different approach here he actually
moved the Rook up to D5 to defend that
A5 pawn and look at this archon not even
taking a moment immediately blitzes out
the move C5 and what he's done is he's
made his intentions clear he wants to
pick up that A5 Pawn but in the bargain
he's made this D6 Pawn such a huge
weakness same with confidence confidence
confidence also very committal and this
is the type of move that I would never
dream of it wouldn't be on my radar I've
got to say I just from the way I was
taught when I was young don't make
long-term weaknesses in your position uh
black certainly has weakened the pawn
structure Roberts talks about the base
of the structure before and Black's
night is tied down forever now Wesley's
Queen has got out of Dodge and yes you
can take that white a pawn that corner
Pawn at any time you want but you might
lose the whole of your Pawn Center in
the process uh yeah very instrumental
decision it's the type of move that has
become more accessible to humans with
the Advent of the engines if you show
this position to a Grandmaster from 1950
they would say what is wrong with you
that C5 move was terrible out of the
question because it completely ruins
your Pawn structure and yet we see the
Eva bar it's sliding slightly in White's
favor but it's because it's hard for
white to do anything The Rook on A1 in
the corner tied down to the defense of
the A5 Pawn The Rook on B5 for black is
staring right at it and the D6 Pawn it's
hard to pile up more pressure on it and
the Knight is a good defender of that
pawn especially when the Rook is leading
the way so I feel like that type of move
has become increasingly common in modern
times but if you went back to that
famous book Zurich 1953 and we're
analyzing with the legends of the day
and show them that move C5 they would
say get out of here this you're not a
strong player our generic icy is strong
he is well aware that he can hold down
the fort despite appearances yeah I do
worry however if the Knight is stuck on
this Square as a defensive piece
therefore The Rook is stuck on this
Square it can never Retreat and this
rook in the Corner may be stuck
defending this uh this loose Pawn then
suddenly Wesley might switch his Focus
switch his attention swing his Rook over
even if it comes at the cost of this
weak a pawn and uh when he does leave
her open the position open things up
then things might turn against the black
king uh suddenly the Black Knight is
caught on the wrong side of the board it
can never act as a Defender Archer does
switch his Rook across and uh what do
you guys think and I'm looking for that
now this was important because if we can
just show this point that Robert was
making that if actually black did pick
up the A5 Pawn giving up the D6 pawn it
just shows what a disaster black spawn
structure would have been you know
you've still got a weakness on Asics the
C5 Pawn is super weak and it just feels
as a Black's position is going to fall
apart which is why Arjun decided to now
reshuffle the position a bit put that
rook in the center it feels to move C5
was made to just make the position once
again get it into a little more Dynamic
territory but very committal there
creates this long-term lifelong weakness
of D6 and I have a bad feeling that this
might come to haunt our journey yeah he
still needs a few moves to arrange the
possible
tree now he has two or three moves to
try and build up whether that's playing
on the other side of the board trying to
push this Pawn forward or not whether he
finds a different plan uh that's what
Wesley's going to be thinking about for
only four minutes against six he needs
to speed up so was he you know he can do
what Dave was suggesting slide The Rook
over to the king side but that creates a
dynamic position that's when the clock
becomes a real factor a Wesley for now
he can kind of sit on the position it's
locked up he can make small moves but
with only four minutes and counting down
on his clock he does not want to enter
tactical territory against origin era
geisi who is an absolute wizard when
pieces are flying
and I think this is where we can see The
Clash of Styles as we've been talking
about if Arjun was playing with the
white pieces David I could have bet that
your idea would have been on the board
with the Rook sliding down to the f file
say give up that pawn on A5 you know I'm
playing for the initiative and if all of
Black's pieces are on the king side we
would have seen that Rook F1 F4 break
that you were hinting at but of course
Wesley keeping everything under control
just going for a more solid approach
keeps the tension as is makes a small
little move H3 and Arjun wanting to keep
the pressure on the clock also makes an
equally useful move when in doubt just
create a little space for your king yeah
and it definitely feels like Wesley is
just maintaining the status quo not
feeling that he can go for it yet with
just three minutes on the clock not
making any uh Dynamic decisions we've
had this uh debate in the past I know a
lot of top chess players they look at
Wesley they see one of the most talented
players out there his instincts just
supreme but uh he doesn't like taking
these risks it's as if he hates losing
more than he enjoys winning and uh it
just feels to me these last supplements
yes he's potentially preparing a pawn
break with F4 but he's not really sure
what to do he doesn't really want to
choose a specific plan and go for it and
the A5 Pawn is a long-term weakness so
if black can slide his Rook up from EA
to E6 defend that pawn on D6 maybe bring
the queen on over to the other side of
the board the A5 Pawn may be falling and
that's what Wesley has to look out for
black doesn't have the time to just put
all the pieces over on the queen side
because that moved F3 to F4 for white
uses a battery ramp open that flank
that's what Wesley needs to consider and
his last move hints at that he brought
his Queen back a square so F4 becomes a
viable option and with that Rook on A1
eventually sliding towards the king side
we could see him take this into tactical
Waters and queen F6 from origin it
prevents that move F4 if we just show
that quickly that would be a huge
blunder because after politics Pawn The
Rook on A1 is in fact loose so it's a
multi-purpose move it defends the pawn
on D6 another time it also prevents that
F4 move which is kind of White's only
big idea I like the way that both
players are handling this they're
keeping the tension the status quo but I
like arjun's clock a bit more because he
has the extra time yeah and both sides
just playing with their kings there it's
definitely a waiting game just both
sides kind of playing copycat moving a
pawn putting the king behind that pawn
it's a waiting game neither side willing
to make that first move to break the
tension and I think we'll have to wait
for a few more maneuvering moves before
finally once I cracks and just lashes
out and either sacrifices a pawn if
you're Wesley so or uh yeah goes for
that pawn if you're Argent erig I see I
like your colorful analysis board now
David yeah I didn't even mean to do the
colors it just it just happened they're
very nice very pretty and we also think
it's very nice when you guys share your
selfies so today this is the air things
monsters every day we are giving out an
air things device signed by Magnus
Carlson himself and we're going to give
out one device today to uh someone who
shares a cool selfie using hashtag chess
Champs on Twitter so go ahead and share
your selfies how are you watching the
show who are you watching with where are
you watching it
we want to know so send your selfie and
preferably in landscape mode and was
that a little bit of a draw offered by
Wesley just shuffling his Queen one step
ahead and then bringing it back in Arjun
saying no I want to play on oh
potentially and uh Arjun of course he's
not known for his tendency to make draws
he's known for being very ambitious he's
a fighter David yeah he'll fight on
surely yeah absolutely he's going to
play this till the end and that's just
his style of play regardless of who he's
playing against and look at those last
couple of moves Robert that Wesley's
gone for the queen went to D2 then a
step back and then it's now back again
to D3 and that just makes one feel that
Wesley perhaps doesn't really know what
he wants to do right now and maybe he's
claiming that black can make no progress
either and there is kind of a hidden
threat the queen is eyeing The Rook on
B5 so if you are not looking out for it
if you make a careless move the queen
when the pawn still existed could have
sacrificed so if we just take a move
back and the Knight didn't take the pawn
uh let's say instead of grabbing the
pawn A5 yeah that move H5 Queen takes B5
is something that you have to consider
because the pawn takes A6 Knights are
very clumsy if the Knight moves back to
save itself then the pawn goes up to A7
it's Unstoppable going to the other side
of the board so I think Wesley was
trying just to move back and forth and
say you are not just going to have a
free hand and now we see that Arjun
takes the pawn A5 but he's Frozen in
place if the Knight moves away now the
A6 Pawn Falls uh if the Knight just
stays on the rim that's looking a bit
dim and that D6 Pawn remains a Target I
think that we're at a bit of a
standstill and white is no worse yeah
he's happily giving out that pawn but
now Arjun is the one with the more
difficult questions to answer and if you
can't bring this Knight into play it's
very very awkward we might see another
repetition of the position if black just
kind of sidesteps yoyos with the Queen
White just sidesteps and yoyos with his
Queen and neither side making progress I
do wonder whether Wesley will be
thinking of sliding the Queen the whole
way across to the corner just to put
extra pressure on that night force it to
move by Brute Force but uh yeah we will
see first of all how Arjun is feeling
about his chances he does sidestep with
his Queen at least he can slide back to
defend this night give it Extra
Protection if he really needs to later
on
but uh still very tense as Robert says I
don't believe white is worth it despite
that pawn deficit temporarily I'm very
impressed with arjun's decision to not
repeat moves even once I don't know if
Wesley intended to actually continue
with the repetition and we'll perhaps
never know that but Arjun makes his
intentions really clear that he wants to
take his chances and this is what we've
been discussing right that Archer needs
to stick to his style he needs to create
Chaos on the board uh has to have that
ice water in my Wayne's approach here
so I I mean against a player like Wesley
with the black pieces most of us well
I'm not even going to put myself in that
category but like most players would be
happy to take a repetition and say you
know what I get white in the next round
you want to repeat I'm happy but Arjun
here fighting this out is that what they
teach in the Indian School of chastanya
I never see you take quick draws either
so we see you fighting out to the very
end
I have you know I've always thought that
uh women chess players female chess
players they have a thing for fighting
it out till the end I don't think we're
very comfortable taking drugs I think
we're Fighters like that ah yeah and I
see Robert looking at me with his
eyebrows raised no nothing new what you
were saying look at the last movie that
was played lastly so also is not in the
business of making a draw and repeating
moves he pushes his Pawn to F4 and he's
saying let's go if he can get one more
move a free turn he would push that pawn
forward and create an attack with his
pawns against the black king So if black
says I don't want any part of that let
me take your Pawn on F4 well thank you
very much my Bishop is finally free
those black pawns on the dark squares
we're making sure that Bishop had
nowhere to go now D6 is hanging three
white pieces attacking it at The Rook on
B5 stuck defending the Knight over there
if the Knight moves back to B7 to defend
the pawn D6 down goes your A6 pawn and
your Rook on B5 is loose and kind of
trapped as well so D6 is a problem point
for our generic icy I think he's going
to regret taking upon on A5 sometimes
your biggest strength is your biggest
weakness and playing Fighting Chess can
backfire and I think we are seeing the
signs of that right now and look at the
clock as well Arjun now
has got less time than Wesley so with
all these trades that have happened the
D6 Pawn is a weakness uh but yeah I was
just uh you know just to finish that
point I think very rarely will you find
um quick draws in uh in women chest stop
events as long as the music Chuck
sisters are not playing
family over everything Robert actually
it's calculation over everything you're
gonna talk to James Kenny a little bit
and uh meanwhile okay look at the
evaluation bar because that black G6
Pawn has dropped yes it's come at the
cost of white Central Pawn but uh if you
count the pieces in the center in the
center of the board white is up those
two black pieces the black Rook the
Black Knight on the edge they're
balanced out by white truck black is
essentially playing a whole night down
and if the attention does switch towards
the king side towards the Kings it's
black who will be suffering so again the
count here doesn't matter stop the count
that black extra Pawn irrelevant and I
really fear for arjun's life here this
turned around really quickly and he's
coming down on the clock as well but
it's it's kind of level here right now
but huge threats with that Rook landing
on with a check on d8 which will force
the king up to a square where it might
pin the rookani for uh so big threats
the one thing that is going for Argent
in here is that Wesley's Rook on A4 is a
little stuck imagine if that could come
all the way down and join the attack
from the f file or the E file that would
be an absolute disaster but this is
looking tricky Arjun needs to keep
control over his nerves and make All the
Right Moves to defend this one yeah
massive threat on the board as Tanya
said there if black just plays kind of
an irrelevant move then there will be a
nasty check and there's nowhere good for
this King to go just to highlight your
point here maybe the safest Square would
be walking into a pin and you don't want
to see that one appear if you're black
so uh huge threat how does he neutralize
that one you could maybe swap off a set
of Rooks at the cost of a pawn but uh
that's a hard move to make because then
you'll always be fighting for only a
draw and it's not Arjun style but maybe
damage limitation is the name of the
game and okay he does choose that move
just to trade off one of White's active
pieces and after a rook trade yes white
takes the pawn back it's level material
now but black still has a bad Knight
against a very strong Bishop but the
fact that Wesley is thinking here
because he would lose his and that is
what I was about to say he was thinking
he does not take the Rook immediately he
says I'm going to trade on my own terms
if you take this Rook if black captured
the queen goes up with check and wins
the night on A5 the geometry of this
position is beautiful in White's favor
so what has Wesley accomplished he's
dragged arjun's King out into the Open
The Rook trade has in fact occurred but
the difference is the black king on F7
which means it could be a queen A7 check
over there there are some issues that
black needs to solve and it's even
material but is not a level game and
eight seconds on the clock for Arjun in
a very difficult position where you need
to make very precise defensive moves a
few seconds left he does retreat his
Knight but the checks don't stop the
pressure doesn't stop check off the
check at the moment and Arjun oh really
lagging behind on the clock and he does
beg for a queen trade if Wesley wants a
really safe uh end game now he just
trades the queens and goes for an extra
Pawn White's Rook is ready to grab a
pawn but of course Black's King is weak
so you should keep the Queens on the
board and uh okay we'll follow that
advice what do you think Tanya
arjun's now hoping that Wesley repeats
with the check but I will be shocked if
Wesley gives Queen F4 check again and
offers a rep Edition I don't believe
that's gonna happen David worst comes to
the West Wesley takes the Queen's off
and tries to go for an end game but uh
yeah I think he'll keep the Queens on as
you said Tanya maybe the key idea at
some point will be to retreat the white
Rook swing it across uh you need to get
it to a better what is happening it's
not going to be a repetition I think
Wesley's gonna bring his Queen on the
diagonal up to C7 with check and freeze
some of Black's pieces when your king is
safer in a position that you want to
keep the Queens on the board so I think
what Wesley is doing is he repeats but
he why would he make a drawer he could
trade Queens go up It Pawn in the end
game so there's no way Wesley so is
thinking let's just make a drawing you
see stock for suggesting Queen C7 check
just bringing the queen to a new square
with check the A6 Pawn is tender if the
Knight drops back oh my gosh he traded
Queens I mean he went for the safe
approach and that's been one of the
biggest problems for Wesley so in his
career so he just takes the safer
approach when he needs to take a little
bit of risk keeping the Queens on the
board and I shouldn't get another life
now I mean he's still down upon and it's
a difficult uh end game to hold but at
least you're not getting checkmated and
Black's Rook is more active than white
stroke whitestruck stuck to the defense
of that weak backwards C Pawn this looks
like there is hope and life still alive
a life still there for Arjun oh but the
clock is ticking we're hurting taking
very quickly and we did see stockfish
gave white a killer Advantage plus five
if he'd kept the Queens on but uh as
you've both mentioned there suddenly
arjun's going to be breathing a sigh of
relief and uh he's getting his pieces
active that Black Brook very strongly
placed now the knights jumping into the
game as well you're hitting that Bishop
on D2 things are getting uh not that
easy for Wesley to convert this one yeah
and he's going to grab a second point
he's currently two pawns up but both the
blacks pieces are on really menacing
squares really active and Robert I think
he might save their Sergeant yeah unless
he is one of the best bullet chess
players in the world so with limited
time on the clock he still can Thrive he
needs to use his outside pass Pawn the H
Pawn and distract Black's forces but
origen looking like he is ready to save
this game those pawns on the queen side
C2 and B3 light squares you have a dark
Square Bishop you can't defend them easy
and that's why we see the liquidation uh
Wesley so up a palm but Arjun Air Guys
he understands his next move will Target
that pawn on B3 and that's what Bishop
E5 what a smart move and maybe Wesley
can still win this yeah still chances
for sure but there is reduced material
so uh arjun's best bet if he can remove
that pawn on B3 uh will be to try and
get rid of all of White's pawns even at
the cost of his own night but the Knight
isn't on a great circuit we've got to
say at the moment he's keeping the white
king out the white king cannot advance
but at some point it might start heading
towards that Lone Ranger that black B
Pawn I still think this is great winning
chances for white uh despite only having
a few pawns left
agrees with you David and that's because
Black's Knight cannot get to that beep
on if we can just take away all the
queen side pawns then this will end in a
draw but now what has happened is that
white actually goes on to pick up the
beef upon what Arjun wants to do is then
fall back with the Knight to C1 there
will be no way to defend the B3 Pawn the
pawns have been traded off and I would
feel that this is a draw but the problem
with the Knight is getting trapped yeah
you're you're not coming back from this
Square you're not finding an any safe
squares later on maybe there's no way to
go for the Black Knight yet as soon as
the white king starts marching towards
it the black king comes down to gobble
up the remaining white Pawn so first
Wesley is fixing that pawn situation on
the king side he's gonna hope that the
black king can't make any uh Headway
towards them but okay now you can start
trying to pick up that night surely
there's a way and
yeah and I was just looking at the clock
okay they're still playing on seconds
and they need to be precise Wesley
they're repeating just one so that he
can get some time on the clock
how is he gonna win that black knight
he's repeated the position twice now he
has to be really careful to avoid the
draw he needs to raise King up there it
is because the Knight goes down the
bishop slides back with check winning
the night on C1 so I think Wesley has
found it the Knight is nowhere to go and
that's why the pawn is pushed oh my gosh
those last pawns get traded even up a
bishop it would still be a draw it's
Wesley winning now he should be we've
got to trust the evaluation bar here
because it's pure calculation the margin
for error uh I'm not sure it's very high
that's the only thing we could see the
evaluation bar drop if he makes one slip
but he should be winning and uh luckily
the White H Pawn is the color it does
promote on the h8 Square a dark Square
so it's the same color as the bishop
okay he didn't trap the Knight he didn't
manage to win it but he's two pawns up
now and the Knight is so far away
should be winning what do we think and
this is the point if the pawn was of the
wrong color David black could have
sacrificed that night saw the F4 pawn
and just get his King to the right
square and it would have ended in a draw
but now Arjun has to fight for this one
it is a winning position for Wesley he
still has to show a little bit of
technique but I believe that Wesley will
do this he will take this point home
yeah the problem is it's always going to
be zooang there's no Fortress here
because the Black Knight has to guard
against two pawns and knights can never
lose time they're the worst piece of
losing time white will just wait with
the Bishop from time to time there we go
just improving the bishop and eventually
slowly but surely the white pawns will
start to advance even further because
sometimes Black's best move is no move
at all you can't do that when you have
Knight Bishops okay if they want to go
up two scores they can stop one square
in between where the Knight has to
change his color complex and we see
Wesley bringing his King over to help
the H Pawn run forward the king will
slide over to G4 the H will go up to H5
and the black king and Knight cannot
stop both pawns at the same time and
that right gone now is so important
otherwise black could have just
sacrificed the night for the pawn that
h8 square being the same color as the
bishop that Wesley has just changes the
result of this game it's working after
Wesley he's improved his position the
Knight as you're mentioning don't have
good waiting moves and at the end we can
see Wesley slowly but surely making
progress with his pawns and his King
yeah two are better than none and those
two white points both promote on dark
swears which is the a bonus but look at
this Black Knight it's a sad situation
here he's got to retreat it all the way
back home Knight and f8 there's no mate
I say but not an f8 here is not going to
help you save the game and they're
advancing eventually you will your
defensive formation will be broken
getting close to 100 moves in this game
yep we're getting very very close but
these players they aren't paid by the
move unfortunately and uh that won't
save Arjun at all uh he's just gonna
wait now he's just gonna move his Knight
back and forth back and forth but
eventually I think there will be ways to
kind of trap that night stalemate that
black knight almost and uh okay first
Wesley's relocating his King bringing
his King the whole whole way round and
uh Black's yeah last blockade isn't
gonna there we go a stalemate of that
black knight the Black Knight has no
moves now without being captured the
black king is gonna have to make way but
uh Wesley will lose a move and uh he'll
find a way eventually to bring his own
King forward there we go zuk Swang no
good moves for black if you could pass
it would be a draw but that's not
possible interest you move the king
anywhere the king steps forward you take
away all the squares the Knight will
have to move somewhere now and it either
gets picked up for free or traded
excellent and gameplay by Wesley this
one yeah and uh last still mate trick it
looks like for marching but it doesn't
work you can take that night either way
with your king or your Bishop it's not
stalemate and I think we have a result
Wesley so has won the game
yep uh has he given up yet our generic I
see yeah he's thrown in the towel yep
Wesley so strikes first chair in the
loser is semi-final he is putting our
generic icy in a must win situation in
game two starting in five minutes
showing no emotion here obviously so but
watch a game he played and here is
today's Lisa vetta learning point
so today's learning point is about
trading pieces on your own terms and one
position one scenario not to trade
pieces is when you have the safer King
here there's a standoff between the two
queens white does have the option of
taking the Queens off the board and
Wesley so against Arjun aragaisy he did
go for this but he almost spoiled his
winning chances he took the win in the
end but with a bit of luck he should
have kept the Queens on the board this
queen check would have been devastating
forcing the Black Knight back and now
white can actually win in a variety of
ways you can go after this Pawn in the
next few moves for white it's extremely
weak you can try and get this Rook back
in the game you can bring your Bishop in
to try and Target this pinned Black
Knight it would have been all over
within a few moves instead Wesley so
traded off and this black king breathes
a sigh of relief it was no longer in
trouble and after recapturing we saw
that suddenly black was on the attack
White had to go passive and black had
great drawing chances so only trade
pieces if it really helps your position
all right we are learning and we're
going to take a quick twitch break right
now for anyone who is not a subscriber
for everyone else well we're gonna
announce the puzzle of today
[Music]
ah ilanka is coming into the studio
we've just seen Wesley wind putting
Arjun in a must win situation in game
two that's gonna be a dramatic game that
is certainly going to be dramatic and I
have to say a very impressive stuff from
Wesley and I have to say it looked like
he'd been reading the Sun Tzu's Art of
War you know a peer week when you are
strong
right I mean I liked that one very good
and talking about great end game
technique he wasn't the only one Fabiana
caruana just defeated uh you yangy with
the black pieces and an excellent Bishop
end game in division two division two
they are playing the winner they are
playing the winners and when it came to
the Grand Final in division three it was
the craziest game I've ever seen in my
life between pragna Nanda and Sam Savion
I've never seen a king get out there in
the middle game so openly but uh it
didn't work out for Sam Sabian so it was
a draw it was it no it was a loss it was
a loss it was a loss So Pregnant takes
the lead with the black pieces
takes the lead in The Grand Final in
division three this is the best of two
games in the Grand Final in division
three two young players fighting it out
there and I said that Ivanka we're gonna
announce the puzzle of today you always
bring Apostle with you for the viewers
on what you have and today today is no
exception and it's actually a study
um composed by afanas afana seif and
here it is it's white to play as always
and it does look like you know even
though white is a knight and two pawns
up well he's in trouble because that
pawn on E2 is gonna promote but how does
white save themselves
ha so the puzzle is white to play why to
play and save yourself save yourself win
I'm gonna leave it up to the viewers to
decide because I think it's a bit of a
giveaway if I tell them yeah okay so uh
here it is get cracking it's a great fun
one as well yeah again another one to
involve the friends the family and once
you've figured it out share it on social
media yeah share it with everyone you
know definitely
all right there you have the puzzle
everyone so get cracking at it but uh
you also need to follow game two in the
loser semi-final it's coming up very
shortly some more action between Wesley
so and Arjun all right guys see your
subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.just.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
mm-hmm
we're getting ready for game two and the
loser semi-final between Wesley so and
Arjun Eric ICN Tanya you said it it's
actually a huge advantage to start out
with the white pieces like Wesley did
here on the losers bracket where there's
only two games and Arjun he's in a
Muslim situation now he has to win on
demand well at least his task is cut out
for him but the bad news is he's playing
Wesley so yeah and Wesley is one of
those guys once he's taken the lead in a
match he goes Super clinical and he's
happy to just play solid not take any
chances he'll just block everything that
you can create well Arjun does have the
white pieces now so I think it really
comes down to what kind of position
comes right out of the opening if it is
something even Robert David I don't
believe that Arjun then has a chance he
has to make sure right out of the
opening we get something absolutely
crazy it's a basically one of the
hardest things to do in chess today to
beat Wesley soul on demand what's this
there was a brick wall you do not want
to punch against it you're going to
break your hand that said Arjun Eric I
see he's willing to lose and that's the
most important thing when you have to
win he doesn't just play a safe style
where he's going to draw the game he
will give it everything he has a play
something maybe dubious that Wesley
doesn't suspect and he needs to catch
Wesley so off guard because when he's
prepared we saw what he did against
Hikaru Nakamura there was nothing he
didn't even bend let alone break I feel
like I want to put that in quotes and
put it on my Twitter account what was it
the most important thing when you have
to win is to be willing to lose very
good all right yeah
what do you expect from Arjun coming
into this must win game David yeah I
also expect him to come all guns blazing
against Wesley so I'm not sure the
opening because he does play Everything
Under the Sun maybe a London system but
with a knight coming to C3 I'm not sure
what we're allowed to call it these days
for that one but uh yeah something
aggressive something that keeps all the
pieces on the board and asks questions
early he did beat Wesley with the white
pieces in the Blitz in the Tata steel a
rapid in India and there we saw jubava
London
so Mike pissing but no he completely
switches it up with one E4 and we've got
an Italian I was hoping for Evans Gambit
but we didn't see that the Evans campers
when white sacrificed the pawn for a
quick initiative I think that's been
proven that it doesn't quite work out
and there is quite a lot of theory that
helps you pair it off so I think we're
getting a solid star thus far I like
this though Bishop G5 just posing some
questions in the early going against
Wesley so yeah the one thing I will say
however about bringing the bishop out to
G5 earlier is that Arjun has been doing
it from time to time recently he played
this in tata steel he's been playing
this in the world Blitz the world rapid
and uh Wesley if he's done his due
diligence and if he's done some research
on this opening he will have been able
to predict uh what Arjun is up to here I
remember Arjun played maybe the most
bizarre looking novelty I've ever seen
against ding in vikan's age just a
couple of weeks ago playing this bizarre
Rook move that no human could ever
understand but a human might recommend
and so far very standard stuff it does
look like black is weakened his King
Side by pushing upon forward to G5 but
he has broken a nasty pin and kicked
back White's dark Square Bishop to a bit
of a blunted square so uh still early
days but uh well-known territory
standard David and as you were
mentioning Robert you're impressed with
that approach with the bishop going to
G5 and the main idea is to try to
provoke black to make these pawn moves
and of course all of this has been done
before we are still in theory but just
having this kind of position where black
has advanced those King Pawns in front
and weaken a few squares you never know
how this will go and the whole idea is
to make it turbulent so I think that's a
good opening approach there's one
problem it seems like Wesley so knows
how this is going to go because he's
throwing his kingside pawns up with
Reckless abandon he's like let's print
G5 let's go H5 and hold nothing back and
that's the sign of a well-prepared
player uh Arjun tried to strike in the
center with D4 Wesley says I'm gonna go
after your minor piece in the king side
brings this queen out to reinforce the
E5 Pawn so it does seem like Wesley
Stone knows everything here that's a big
problem for origin area guys see I like
the type of position we have but I also
like Wesley so's preparation yeah Dr
goldon in the twitch chat saying when is
the last time Wesley so even lost a game
never yeah he never loses yeah wow
literally this tournament he's unbeaten
so far uh two title Tuesdays Vikings
they didn't lose the game I don't think
he's lost in 2023 yet yeah what a what a
year it's so amazing and he said one of
his goals for 23 is to win a big online
event and it looks like he wants to make
the most of the second shot that he has
well he did win it last year with a
global championship and Wesley saw
taking the lead in this match and
playing confidently and taking his
chances in the second one as well yeah
the winner of this match will go through
to face Hikaru Nakamura and the losers
final starting right after this match
has finished and the winner of the
losers final will meet Magnus Carlsen in
the grand final tomorrow
will it be Wesley so will it be our
generation or Hikaru Nakamura and Kaya
on your birthday uh what do you want to
see do you want to see Arjun uh win this
one fight back from again or do you want
to see a Wesley sir against Hikaru
Nakamura uh final I I want to see
Armageddon
whoever it is
so is a very nice guy so if he hears
this he probably would say all right
Kyle Armageddon for your birthday sounds
like a nice present and we are getting a
fight that could lead to that Armageddon
but every single turn it feels like
Wesley so is moving instantly that must
strike some fear into our generic I see
he needs to win this game but the
position is incredibly Dynamic right now
we see the black king side it is open
there you've thrown your pawns forward
which means they're weak squares left
behind and white has given up the bishop
the last move capture the Knight on C6
and then black was able to capture back
so the pawn structure is bad on the left
side of the board the Queen side and the
the rights of the board the king side
because the pawns are sticking out like
sore thumbs that said the bishop on A7
such a strong piece for black staring
all the way across the board to the
enemy King I feel like Wesley you know
he's now slowing down he might finally
be out of preparation yeah and uh just a
few moves ago we saw him pause for 30
seconds he looked off to his left side
and normally when players are staring
off to the left staring off into the air
uh they're activating that side of their
brain which is the memory part where so
he was just recalling his opening notes
but now for the first time he's really
looking into the board trying to work
things out so I think you're right
Robert he's on his own for the first
time in this game and it's not the type
of position you want to be on your own
you want to know exactly what's going on
here because multiple threats white is
eyeing up this Pawn this Pawn is
undefended or not sufficiently defended
right now at this point you could at
least hint at capturing at some point
and how does Wesley deal with both of
those threats you don't want to take out
time out now and just play an ugly
looking move you don't really have the
luxury of lining things up and defending
and of course he plays dynamically more
energetically he attacks the White Queen
instead so once this White Queen moves
it's not clear where she goes but for
example if she steps up there might be a
drawback the Bishops will suddenly allow
line and look at this nasty pin along
this diagonal combine it with this
bishop and this is nasty stuff for white
so I'm more expecting Arjun now to slide
the other way with this queen okay he
has gone out I was going to say maybe
offer a trade of Queens because you do
have the better Pawn structure long term
but Arjun remember he's a much more
ambitious player than me and he does go
after these black weaknesses many many
pawns off for grabs now I'm into it I
really like the way origin is playing
what's this so is capable of playing
energetic Dynamic style but he's forced
into it in this game he really didn't
have a choice based on arjun's opening
so Arjun picking a great opening and a
must win game and now the dynamic is
very difficult for black to deal with
because C6 is hanging If you defend that
pawn E5 is loose so you have multiple
pawns hanging and look at Wesley so play
he brings his Knight to F6 the reason
why is the bishop on A7 is a very
powerful piece his next move will be a
knight jump over to H5 where he attacks
the bishop which is not defended there
is a pawn connecting to it but that pawn
is pinned and so White's pieces on the
king side those minor pieces not really
doing all that much so giving up
material for the activity and Wesley so
knows it's well worth it this is a
stunning move what a way to defend the
position you just go for the offense and
just taking Robert's point forward uh
you know you can pick up that pawn on E5
the Central Pawn the keep on in Black's
position with two pieces but both bad
idea is that Knight comes in Knight H5
and your Bishop is suddenly trapped you
don't have a good Square for it
everything's hanging the Knight on E5
will be hanging or you lose the bishop
on the other hand just to point out the
power of that Bishop on A7 if you pick
that E5 phone up with the bishop then
David you got this Banger move G3 on the
board just blasting the position open
that Bishop on A7 an absolute monster
you can't grab that G3 pawn bishop takes
G3 you say wait what just happened
nothing happened because there's a pin
you simply pick up the bishop with your
queen thank you very much game over and
which is why Wesley goes uh for this
move Knight F6 Arjun responds with a bit
of greed but for the other Pawn takes
the pawn on C6 and for now The Rook on
A8 is under attack so you don't have the
time to make the move Knight H5 what I'm
expecting from Wesley is a simple
developing move you can move that Bishop
from C8 and say my Rook is defunded if
you want to pick up the C7 Pawn go ahead
but then once again the Knight can find
its way to H5 but Rook C8 would be even
stronger picking up that night on C4 yep
a bunch of tactics here in the air and
uh once Wesley does defend uh his Rook
or develop his Bishop then the threats
will be maintained they will continue
and uh Arjun has to make sure they don't
spiral out of control I'm looking at the
clock times Arjun does have 14 minutes
so it feels like he's still in or around
his opening preparation it's something
he's cooked up at home but uh yeah it
certainly is the type of position that
could go anyway in either direction and
for Wesley that's not 100 comfortable
when he only needs to draw and look at
his chest pose now yeah that is full of
focus we haven't seen that one from
Wesley yet yeah that's like Batman type
of focus it's like making a mask with
his own hands
in there yeah not letting anything from
the outside world distract him Wesley so
big decision to be made still a decent
position according to the eval bar so uh
we've got to assume that his Pawn
sacrifice was justified objectively
correct but so hard to handle for humans
this one it's not the same exact
position that happened in the Olympia
but I'm just recalling a game between no
dierberg Abdul sataurav and patalahari
Krishna because in the Olympiad
Christian beat him with black and was
able to win a really nice game and
important game for the Indian team so it
has that same Contours where black goes
for the attack the king looks a bit
exposed Black's pawns look overextended
but really it's White's king that's in
danger but I do like this I keep saying
it that Arjun Eric I see he doesn't mind
losing he may lose this game but he is
begging Wesley so to answer important
questions do you have enough
compensation that vague term for
sacrifice material you're down one Pawn
right now and that 9 on C4 which is
attacking multiple pawns it can always
swing back to block that Bishop on A7
the other night from H2 can go back next
to the King on F1 and you can just put
your pieces together make sure that you
have a compact structure and then you
say to Wesley you sure you're good you
are down upon it might become two but
Arjun right now is a man who has nothing
to lose a jaw or a loss Will mean the
same thing so only one result works out
for him which also helps him make these
Brave decisions once he's taken this
step of moving the queen in One
Direction he has to pick up those pawns
and ask Wesley the question show me what
you got show me where your money is and
Wesley with this Pawn structure having
already lost the pawn needs to continue
with the momentum with the pressure on
with the initiative and not care about
material anymore it is all about the
attack that he can build against white
skin against that Bishop on G3 Wesley
slowing down a little bit and look at
that clock look at that clock Wesley's
got eight minutes Arjun state in a
minute up till now and he was shaking
his head slightly Wesley so you're not
happy at all out of his comfort zone he
wanted a stable Pawn structure where he
could just slowly maneuver slowly find
his way into the game the one thing I
will say from personal experience is uh
you don't want to poke the bat if you
poke Wesley he'll he'll come at you
he'll find a way because he's so
Universal when he needs to be when he
wants to be but right now he's not
enjoying it too much I'm expecting him
to go for a move that you mentioned that
Tanya just moved the light Square Bishop
I'm not sure where you move it for black
but just connect your Rooks and go from
there the threats will continue but we
do hope uh you guys at home are enjoying
the air things monsters and enjoying the
show that once they saw in Arjun
aragaisy is putting on right now I know
some people are enjoying a watch party
together right now at the good night
look at that
air things uh people at the good night
having a watch party enjoying the chess
that is very cool maybe we should go to
the good night later today oh it's so
fun it's my favorite place here I mean
if anyone's in Oslo find yourself here
any time of the year you've got to go to
the good night it is the coolest chess
pop that I've ever seen yeah I'll race
you there after the photo I want to know
the air quality there as well sweetest
yeah but you have the you know Advantage
because you're a local you know how to
get there Tanya's relying on you
we can we can ski there so you can guess
and you have them yeah you have you have
a bunch of good memories from the good
night now you did really well in the pub
quiz together with Magnus Carlsen you
guys teamed up and you won the chess
game together with Tanya against David
and Ivanka
happy birthday
but yeah we're all having a good uh time
at the good night when we go there this
chess club in Oslo
and uh meanwhile Robert I profit again
dropping the night back now uh Arjun
very safe Square I just love it uh
keeping things compact as you described
and keeping things nice and safe look at
the clock right now Wesley so is down to
about 6 minutes 20 seconds and Arjun has
barely spent any time so I think for
Wesley one of the pivotal questions that
he's asking himself is how much deeper
is origin's preparation we saw Arjun
impress Vichy Anand at the Tata steel
event in India where he was saying oh I
have this 10 more moves and it was
already moved 30. so this is scary for a
player it may objectively be okay for
black but you make one mistake and that
evil bark jumps up and says that white
has a huge Edge so I think right now for
Wesley he needs to bring his Knight over
to the rim we keep talking about these
ideas the Knight attacking the bishop he
needs to go forward he doesn't have time
to pause he is down material but that
White Knight on H2 will simply slide
back home to F1 and say what attack do
you really have we have seen in previous
days the black king Magnus Carlsen try
to do something like this slide up the
board The Rook go to its starting square
and try to deliver a Checkmate down the
H file that seems very far away but we
see with Wesley's last move that he
feels that now is the time he needs to
pounds yeah he needs to pounce then
again Knight Sarah King's best friend
and these are two very very strong
Defenders the two white Knights and uh
there we go one of them drops back to F1
keeping everything under control and
that's the big question I feel here is
black quick enough you're still a pawn
down more pawns to follow this Pawn
about to drop and uh yeah is this plan
quick enough it costs one move to move
the king cost two move to move the Rook
maybe uh three moves to move the knights
and then four five to Checkmate I don't
know if you get that time
you know with this last move that
Wesley's made it looks like he's doing
everything right but once again Arjun
just blitzing out that night Retreat
again feels like he's in his preparation
you were talking about how he impressed
Wishy earlier Tata steel and that was a
preparation up to move 36. we're
currently on move 19. it was a game
against nehal Suri and the helmet one
blunder and that was all over and that
was all the way up to move 36. at this
level your prep needs to be deep some
say as deep as true love oh deeper
wasn't that in the Italian game as well
am I mistaken which opening was that one
that he prepared all the way to move 36
yeah the one again and the last move was
this small pawn move F3 which wins the
game in this end game if you haven't
looked at it you guys have to check it
out brilliant brilliant prep there and
just really nice ideas and Wesley is
going to be breathing aside of relief
because For the First Time Arjun has
properly stopped to think so so maybe
not that deep his opening preparation
not as deep as move 36 but it's moved 24
impressive stuff by the way but it's
either relief or fear because sometimes
when your opponent starts thinking after
all the prayers it means you made a
mistake so you typically see the first
three lines of the engine saying these
are the top moves and then maybe
Wesley's like did I just make the fifth
best move and my position is bad but I
do think we have seen our generic I see
he left his preparation he's on his own
he does have some standard looking moves
to play his rook in the corner isn't
doing much he can slide it towards the
center and I he is up a pawn for now he
should be feeling pretty good about his
chances here and he knows that he is not
just making a simple strategic draw he
is going to fight to The Bitter End this
is the exact type of position that he
wanted and now he's got it he has a lead
on the clock he should continue to use
the clock as a weapon that's an eight
minute lead on the clock and that's
gotta count for something the Queens are
still on the board it's a complete mess
and of course Wesley has things under
control so far but he still has some
difficult decisions coming up and one
can imagine those challenges with the
spawn structure that black has he would
need and require some time to navigate
those Waters it really looks like in a
win-on-demand situation arjun's got the
dream scenario regardless of what the
eval Bar says yeah so how much time
would you want to invest here it's a
crucial position you're finally out of
your preparation you have to think on
your own two feet how much would you
invest two three more minutes or would
you just try to get a few quick moves
down on the board to keep the pressure
on Wesley
it is very critical here for Arjun as
well as you mentioned it's very possible
that his preparation is now over and
this is New Territory for Arjun he
perhaps realizes that he needs to keep
his chances alive needs to keep the
initiative going can't trade off too
many pieces I would say another minute
or two but he needs to keep that
pressure on the clock that is absolutely
key for this match I would say another
minute David if he takes longer than
that Wesley's confidence grows and every
second that Arjun is spending to think
on the board Wesley is getting that
additional time we can see him on the
camera it's not as if he's looking
around chilling he is calculating right
now so Arjun the more time he takes the
more time Wesley gets yeah and we see
Wesley kind of a bit Restless bobbing
his head there he's calculating as you
say but also uh yeah getting a bit
excited maybe he's proud of himself
finding a move that Arjun hasn't looked
at I don't know if arjun's got
photographic memory but I'm impressed
that he's memorized to move 24 these
days I forget things by move three or
four but uh in the end playing the most
natural move a bit odd to spend almost
four minutes and then just centralize
your Rook this looked like an automatic
almost but uh yeah it makes sense Robert
just trying to get Rooks off the board I
don't think we care that we're
potentially dropping the white A2 Pawn
black isn't gonna have the time to go
and take that one so uh very logical
move how does Wesley keep the attack
going and uh he's back in the tank again
just a strong move because now he is
offering a trade of Rooks at some point
he remains upon ahead and Wesley says I
can't hold back any longer let me take
that Bishop the Knight on F1 has to take
back so for origin it's a bit confusing
to me because he either can throw in an
exchange of Rooks or just take back the
Knight with his Knight of course Knight
takes Knight seems like the most obvious
choice so what is he really thinking
about yeah he uh eventually makes that
decision and now a bit of calculation to
be done because one of the nights has
disappeared it was temporarily a couple
of Bishops against a couple of knights
normally you favor the Bishops but black
support down had to do something
concrete and he's banking on the fact
that White's King maybe on the back rank
might face some problems and you don't
really want to recapture this bishop
ever with a pawn you've wreck your own
structure but it looks like they're
going to have a full sequence of moves
now because with these trades now you
don't want to capture that Bishop with
the pawn if you if you do that then
black picks up the Rook on D1 and well
you watch out for that Rook on it but
the Rook can go back to d8 and you're
fine the E3 Pawn is also weakness you've
kind of destroyed your own Pawn
structure so with that black white has
to trade oh wow I was just going to say
white has to trade the Rooks first but
instead Arjun says none of that because
that would just lead to a lot of Trades
and no chances for white he does go for
this ugly looking Pawn structure but
keeps pieces on the board yeah you
predicted It Again by accident that time
Tanya well done uh I hope you really did
buy a lottery ticket after yesterday and
meanwhile now we're predicting the black
Rook to drop back Wesley pauses is he
really considering a queen trade right
now uh it would be up his alley it would
be his style but he is a pawn down so
dropping the queen back pretty much
forcing the Queens to come off is a
potential option what do you think
Robert great choice for Wesley and when
he pauses that that's when I start
thinking what I initially am
anticipating is probably wrong so I
think he is going to slide the queen
back because the Queens have to come off
after Queen data once those Queens are
off the board the A2 Pawn can actually
be captured with Queens on with heavy
pieces there that pawn do you want to
capture your Bishop can get trapped now
the black Rook is looking to slide into
D2 with activity along that file the
Pawns in the center for white are very
ugly and the Knight on G3 has nowhere to
go because the bishop on E6 is perfectly
placed so wow actually Wesley decides to
keep even more material off important he
gives him a rook that's a sacrifice he's
just I think he's supposed to draw this
is just incredible we were assuming he
had to defend his Road move his Rook or
swap the Queens he says no just take my
Rook please he moves out of check and
that's a mark of Genius Wesley so if
Rook takes Rook now Queen takes pawn and
there's not that many squares for the
king to go to you can't go towards the
center whoops suddenly it checks and uh
oh sorry that was one oh that was the
announcement sorry this would be
just to show what white shouldn't do but
if you go the other way if you go to the
side with your King The Black Queen
drops back with the check and either you
allow a repetition which doesn't suit
the match situation for Arjun erag icy
or you have to throw a knight in the way
but you might well regret this after
Queen takes Knight if you do start
retreating with the King for example the
pawn will move whoops Checkmate is going
to come uh two threats here you can go
forward with your king maybe but Black's
attack will continue the White Queen is
so far away remember we've mentioned
this when a queen is divorced from a
king your king will get attacked and uh
devastating threats on board but
basically it's super easy for Arjun to
go wrong here yes this is a mark of
Genius what Wesley has done just moving
that King forward calculating this line
This is why Wesley is one of the best
players in the world and once you're
behind in a match it is impossible to
come back in it with this guy I mean
look at this move King G7 cat dating it
till the end look at Wesley right now he
knows it that he's got this in the bag
brilliant game brilliant seriously
brilliant from start to finish because
it seemed like he was out of his book
early in the preparation was up origin's
alley it was a dynamic game and yet here
we are saying the only choice for white
that doesn't lose in the spot allows a
draw by force repetition uh Arjun he was
going to look for something he knows he
doesn't have anything Wesley so just
earned himself a spot to face off
because he only have one move now origin
he only has one move and it's the move
we were showing even in that variation
uh it's nothing more than a draw for
white at maximum Rook takes Rook is the
only move not to resign right now it's
obvious he will play this one after a
bit of thought but it's sinking in now
on generic guys after Rook takes Rook as
we showed Queen takes porn forces the
king to the side of the board the Queen
will yo-yo between the H6 square and the
E3 E3 square and it's just going to be a
draw well there's one more move that
Arjun does have but unfortunately for
him it doesn't work David if you just
bring up the live board one more time
white can throw in a check with the
Knight on H5 in the current position
Justin distract that Queen from that E3
Pawn but it is the geometry just doesn't
work out for white because black simply
snaps up the Knight if you pick up the
Rook you might think you won an exchange
but that g Bond Marches On The Board G3
you're threatening Queen H2 and very
importantly The Rook on D1 hangs as well
and in fact black is the one who comes
on top after this yeah black will be
winning if uh Arjun tries to keep going
uh the game going sorry and uh simply
nothing else to be done poor Arjun he's
played a good game he prepared really
really well but genius from Wesley so to
shut this one down and force the draw
the aid of a rook sacrifice just
incredible stuff in G7 it's been a
Wesley so Match Game one it was a
position where he was slightly better
pressing he was able to convert that
into a full point here in game two he
showcases his excellent preparation it
seemed like only Arjun knew what he was
doing but wasis just was slowing down
because of how dangerous the position
gets if you don't play the accurate
response and we're talking about Wesley
so here maybe the most accurate player
in history among the best for sure and
he just does not make mistakes very
often that's why throughout the year so
far he's lost practically no games in
classical chess he had two wins and all
the rest draws and taught to steal in
title Tuesday he drew a couple games won
all the rest against Hikaru Nakamura
they drew all five games but he had the
white pieces in the Armageddon and now
against our generic geissi the only
player who has beaten Magnus Carlson
here in the air things Master it's just
a Wesley so show and look at him he's
such a humble guy Wesley so but sitting
there just like oh yeah yeah and I'm
sure you know once he's it looks like
this is going gonna be over really soon
when he does join us I know he's going
to have a lot of good words for Arjun to
say very encouraging always to the
younger generation uh yeah Wesley so is
perhaps one of probably the kindest top
10 players in the world
he is he's number one he's 2900 when it
comes to just being a nice guy he's just
a nice guy he really engages in the
trash talk that we see between uh top
players from time to time and uh yeah
Audrey we mentioned the sponsorship deal
he's been so good this last 12 months
but uh he'll learn from this much and
he'll move on and he'll uh learn yeah
he'll take a lot of tips from it just
from how Wesley's guided this game to
safety won the last one impressive stuff
by both players I've got to say you know
guys we've seen so many amazing games so
far but I have to say for me King G7 is
perhaps the most stunning move in the
whole event so far I mean it's just such
a little move so unexpected we were
looking at The Rook retreating the queen
blocking the check
but Wesley here just moves the king up
has calculated this till the end it's
just aesthetically so pleasing to end
the game like this yeah some people ask
me you know what separates the very best
from the rest of us even from other very
strong grandmas is what separates the
real elite and its moose like that when
you just have the presence of mind to
stop to realize there are alternatives
not just to play the most obvious moves
a lot of us we don't have that impulse
control we just play moves because they
look like they're forced or they look
natural uh but these top players they uh
yeah they have this other dimension and
they they see things like this they have
the imagination to see these tactics and
yeah he's flowed through it's going to
be a draw and it's often said against
Magnus Carlson if you don't draw the
immediately when the draw is kind of
offered not by his hand but by the
position if you don't make it you are
likely to lose and that's what Wesley
soldiers did he figured I can make a
draw on the spot that way I don't get in
any danger and Arjun he's throwing all
his pieces forward but his King is the
one who's about to be hunted Wesley so
is not worried about the queen and the
Rook lining up right now his Queen can
Venture into H2 go down to the corner
give some checks win some material but
the one but in this position is if you
allow that white king to escape then the
extra material can make its presence
felt especially with the queen The Rook
lined up towards the black king yeah so
let's try to find the Checkmate the bar
has gone all the way in Black's favorite
now black is winning Arjun he didn't
want the draw he's falling on his own
sword here uh but how does black get
there does the check do the business it
looks like the evaluation bar reacts to
that so the most obvious move still good
for black still good enough for Wesley
uh here I was going to suggest maybe a
bishop check being one of the options
you could give another queen check as
well still looks very very good for
black but maybe there's something even
more effective I think Wesley will jump
in with the queen just because it looks
so direct you can grab a few pawns I
don't think the white king can run away
far enough from the checks you get
minimum a draw and that's good enough
for Wesley but maybe there's something
better is it to do with stopping some of
these checks preempting some of these
checks uh what do we think here in the
studio I think we've got a move already
yeah it's given a check and the King has
move to F1 yeah it's absolutely tempting
to pick up this G2 Pawn with the check
as well you can always push that F5 Pawn
the only threat that white has is The
Rook jumping onto G8 to give a check so
this is always an option to keep things
under control
looks very classy that one and the white
screen is so far away she's unable to
ride to the rescue and uh yeah again I
would be just restraining myself I would
be wanting to give a check with the
queen or with the bishop to the white
king uh just to follow okay there we go
I was gonna say well let's follow
through this variation but the king
moves yes we just take another Pawn the
king can run but we continue checking it
and it's not going to run far enough uh
to save this game I don't see a mate
though David do you see a mate here I
don't see a mate but the problem is if I
keep checking you anytime you drop back
with the Rook I can just move my queen
and this Pawn okay the evaluation part
doesn't like what I'm doing but uh there
will be more accurate moves yeah you
could take the Rook oh wow
and there we go black makes a new Queen
and this is the only way that uh Arjun
can avoid the draw we're seeing this
being played out by the way exactly the
line that you caused the king is on C2
right now so a check on F2 or E2 by the
queen and then this queen sack that will
be stunning yeah yeah stunning maybe
white can pick up a few Pawns in that
variation wow we accidentally predicted
the whole future the whole sequence of
moves you're the prophet now in the
house we all need to put on the back for
that one especially Robert when Queen
takes Rook happens in a moment Arjun has
nothing else to do he will drop back his
Rook if he wants to keep this game going
but then we'll see that nice little
trick from Wesley I am I am a little
confused because uh the bar is in the
middle here so is this genius by Wesley
getting the draw he needs to go through
yes oh can he win this game well he he
could have won but he sees a draw and he
knows that's enough for him to go
through so it seemed that he could have
pushed his Pawn next to his King just to
take away the white threat of bringing
the Rook down the last rank but we see
he's moving his Queen back and forth and
he has secured the draw at minimum if
origen tries to avoid the draw he just
loses so I think it's just smart match
play for muscle cell yeah yeah and we've
seen it from Wesley before he's very
practical if there's even one percent
risk in another variation he won't
choose it if he can find an alternative
to removes any doubt whatsoever and now
we see the position repeat itself
that's it Arjun had no option it's over
Wesley so takes the match he goes
through to face Hikaru Nakamura and the
losers final to start in 10 minutes and
look at that confident face of Wesley so
how impressed are you with him after
this match Robert just typical chess
blurry yeah know what he's doing right
now he's looking over that game seeing
if there are any improvements but it was
a perfect demonstration by him
withstanding the pressure at the opening
playing every accurate move and then
going after his enemy King Wesley so is
a monster and he's earned himself a spot
in division one the next event that
comes around so of course he's just
thriving in the Champions chess tour yep
there is no doubt now we definitely will
see Wesley so Hikaru Nakamura and Magnus
Carlsen because they will be top three
in division one in the air things
monsters they have qualified for
division one in the next event but who's
gonna win the tournament we don't know
that yet Grand final is tomorrow and
it's going to be either Wesley so or
Hikaru Nakamura to face Magnus Carlsen
the losers final will start now in a
little less
than 10 minutes and Wesley so we'll be
going into that against Hikaru Nakamura
with a bunch of confidence after this
game David yeah an incredible game to
finish off that match and uh
commiserations to Eric our generic I see
he'll be back he'll be stronger but
today he ran into uh Wesley so in beast
mode and it was this position Wesley
initiated a trade of Rooks he captured
the white Rook white recaptured with a
nasty check and here in the studio we
were predicting a block there's two
sensible ways to block this check you
can Retreat your rook and uh Force the
White Queen away or you can force a
trade of Queens going into a very
respectable end game by sliding back but
of course Wesley had seen one step
further he'd seen a third option and he
simply moved his King this relies on a
tactic after Rook takes Rook that after
Queen check the white king cannot Escape
instead we saw Arjun almost fall on his
sword there he gave away a knight he was
actually losing the game but just trying
to preserve some winning chances Wesley
however didn't allow any of that a draw
and he moves on
we're joined by Arjun Air Guys who's
given it an amazing fight in the air
things monster but now knocked out how
are you Arjun
hey um
it was a great match I think board games
were pretty close
in the first effect maybe I should have
just taken a joy in the first game
and second one I think I
I basically taught after effectively
when Queen night is forced to go back
but I forgot that I can mode again
yeah and what a game uh that second game
by Wesley where he only needed the draw
you were in that must win uh what was
your reaction when when Wesley played uh
was it uh King to G7
yeah at that point I realized I messed
up and I don't it's always inevitable
and I just went for this pretty much out
of desperation but that didn't help
either
Arjun you put up a Really Brave fight
today one of the big highlights in this
event has been that you are the only
player so far who has defeated Magnus
here that must be a special takeaway
from this one
you have the definitely the match
against Magnus was great I
the few previous matches that I played
with him were all ended in three games
so I I was quite happy that it went all
the way to uh Megan yeah and Arjun
what's coming up next for you now what's
your plans in the near future
honestly I have no idea
eggplant until
May so I have to see all right well we
hope to see you in the next event in the
Champions chest or thank you so much for
all the entertainment and for joining us
thank you bye thank you Arjun and we're
actually also joined by Wesley so uh who
is very shortly going to start the
losers final against Hikaru but
congratulations on winning the match
against Arjun Wesley
yeah thank you very much thank you guys
I'm you know I'm happy to still be in
the tournament and uh I I mean there are
a pavilion Road for this year's
Champions Chester but I think I qualify
for next
uh for April right you are now
guaranteed division one in the next
event what's that mean to you yeah it's
huge so that's exactly what I was
fighting for today uh not necessarily
the price but to have to avoid doing the
play in because it's very tough also
I'm going to Germany on tomorrow we're
leaving
for Germany and I'm playing two
tournaments there one is in Dusseldorf
one is Berlin and our ticket is uh
scheduled to go back on March 13 which
is the exact day of the play in so I
really wanted to avoid that one
yeah yeah it's it's big winning today
against Arjun was big yeah and and and
what's a match you played especially
that second game that King G7 move our
experts in the studio are saying it's
one of the best moves of the tournament
how happy are you if you're playing that
game yeah King G7 King H7 also draws uh
yeah but I actually didn't freaking G7
until he took my Rook because I was
gonna play Queen d8 and go to the end
game and you know but King King moving
the king forces the door right away so
what's uh
was very pleased I mean it can't
necessarily be the best move because I
mean the prettiest move because it only
makes a draw but actually the way Arjun
played in the end turns out black is uh
winning but I was very pleased because
Arjun is an amazing player I have a lot
of respect for him
I think Fabiano caruan also mentioned
that out of all the Indian youngsters
seems Arjun has a lot tons of potential
and they could possibly reach 2800 one
day but uh
but it's nice also it's a pure Edition
like it's very good in the openings so
I'm very happy to uh you know to do well
in the opening against him uh today in
both games uh well the first game I mean
the second game
I was very happy I was able to remember
my preparation because I think I pretty
much prepared it until move 24 or
something like that move 23. so I didn't
have any problems there but when he took
the pawn C6 I spent a long time
considering Bishop D7
Queen 57 Knight H5 Knight F1 but I
didn't see anything but after Bishop E6
turns out black has absolutely no
problems so that was all nice because
whenever white plays this Italian with
Bishop G5 the position gets very complex
and black has to remember a lot of
things it's dangerous for both colors
um and the first game was also very
interesting with Ruben D5 I think he
made a slight mistake with Bishop takes
Knight early on
I think the bishop on M6 was very well
placed uh and then later on I think he
should have just taken the Drone
repeated moves but it was very risky for
black to keep playing and I I was just
trying to find the right time to break
with F4
and so both games were very interesting
there were a lot of things to to discuss
uh and there were a lot of crucial
moments but uh yeah it's nice
yeah Wesley congratulations on winning
this game and now there's a big final
coming up in your bracket and just
really quickly maybe you can tell us how
you're looking at this matchup against
Hikaru in this one
oh yeah I mean
well he he beat me two days ago yeah
so uh uh you know he's
I mean he's probably the favorite
because he he's very good that this time
control this format
uh you know hopefully I can do better
this time I'm not sure what his strategy
will be but for the last two matches
against Magus and myself he was taking
it to the Armageddon which I think is a
very good match strategy so we'll we'll
see if he does the same thing today but
uh do you want to avoid Armageddon
against Hikaru Wesley or is that a good
match tragedy for you as well
yeah to be honest I would prefer to
avoid it I mean he's oh the time control
gets shorter and shorter he's uh his
Advantage gets bigger and bigger so
preferable to avoid it but in in my
match against him two days ago I didn't
really had any things substantial
uh
well you know I'll just give my person
just happy to qualify for on the April
event and hopefully I can what a good
fight against uh certainly sorry to
play some good chess we're looking
forward to it Wesley it starts in only a
few minutes we really appreciate you
stopping by and talking to us before
this match against Chicago good luck
yeah wish me well yeah
all right and also Robert I want to say
thank you for the good collaboration in
the Olympian a few months ago and we'll
win the next one all right we'll see
well we'll see how you do next but
congratulations so far and thank you for
those kind words
yeah thank you
Wesley so it's getting ready for uh the
big losers final against Hikaru Nakamura
the winner of that match will make it
through to tomorrow's Grand Final to
phase Magnus calls how cool that he
actually stopped by and talked to us
before it starts he's such a nice guy
like you know we of course I was the
coach of the US team at the Olympiad and
so we worked together a bit and he
didn't have to just you know say that to
me but he's always just so you know kind
and he always Wishes the best for
everybody but he can't wish the best for
Hikaru he has a lot of respect for him
we heard him say when the clock ticks
Downs when the car was at his best so
we'll I think we're gonna see a fighting
Wesley so in the best of two rapid games
here it's going to be intense it starts
in a few minutes if you're not a
subscriber on Twitch we're gonna send
you now to a twitch break before it
starts
[Music]
it's an intense format this season on
the Champions chest or Wesley so only as
a few minutes to get ready for another
match the losers final is best out of
two games and if they are tied then it
will be decided in Armageddon Hikaru
Nakamura is in there because he lost
yesterday's winners final against Magnus
Carlsen and Wesley predicted David that
Hikaru wants to take this to Armageddon
what do you think what will this match
be like it's so hard to call Kaya both
of them are unbeaten we can't forget
that neither of them have been hit in
this tournaments and uh just that one
match between them was decided by
Armageddon it was so close Hikaru got
black in that which was decisive
eventually
I still think Armageddon is 50 50. it's
about who gets the black pieces it's
about the psychology of the bidding war
and uh I do have a feeling that that
will decide it it's just too hard to
separate them yeah and I was going to
ask Wesley what his strategy is going to
be in terms of bidding if you learn
anything from Magnus yesterday and his
own bidding against a car the day before
but I felt he might answer the question
and that's bad for his match strategy I
didn't want you know hikar to listen and
hear it so Wesley being such a kind
person he wouldn't have left me on red
so I feel like you know it's better not
to ask him let his actions do the
talking yeah and he did say he wants to
avoid the arvaghetto Wesley so let's
take a look at the bracket this is day
four in the air things monsters we
started out with quarterfinals on Monday
four players made it through to the
winners semi-finals and uh for players
were knocked down to the losers bracket
we did have a winners final yesterday
between Magnus Carlsen and Hikaru and
Nakamura Magnus Carlsen won that in a
dramatic take Armageddon to make its
route to tomorrow's Grand Final we will
now follow follow the losers final
between Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so
best out of two rapid games with 15
minutes plus three seconds increments
and if they are tied it will go down to
Armageddon some Tanya what do you think
Hikaru has been doing today do you think
he's been following Wesley do you think
he's been preparing what has the car
been up to you mean if he's not been
streaming or or maybe he has been maybe
he's been streaming I think but if he's
not he's definitely been keeping an eye
on that match and thinking about his own
strategy as well Hikaru would love a
rematch against Magnus but of course so
would Wesley we've been talking about
how this double elimination bracket is
such a good showcase for the best
players to show their ability and here
we've got the three favorites who've
actually the heavyweights who've
qualified for the next tournament and
the fight is amongst them Magnus Hikaru
and west see this is what we dream of
from a tournament I think Wesley made a
really good point by the way I want to
say that I can't imagine any other chess
player doing what he did to just come
and talk so openly about what the match
that he had but also his Outlook towards
what's coming up it was just incredible
to get his thoughts so much appreciated
and I think what he said that he wants
to avoid the Armageddon I think that
makes sense for Wesley yeah Wesley will
try and settle this one in the rapid all
right oh they have faced each other a
bunch of times Hikaru knock him around
Wesley so both playing for the US it is
in favor of Hikaru does that mean he's
also a favorite in this match Roberts
well lately it's turned around in
Wesley's favor we did see a car take him
down an Armageddon the other day but
that Global Championship that earned
Wesley has spot through to division one
the air things master that was one on
the biggest stage by Wesley so that was
an eight game match five to three in
Wesley's favor he's proven that he he
could take down akaru history says the
car was the favorite Wesley says the car
was the favorite but today is a new day
and maybe Wesley can come with his best
stuff and take down akaru like he has in
the place yeah he's definitely coming
with confidence after some fantastic
play against Arjun Eric icy Hikaru
Nakamura is ready
and what do you think David what do you
expect from the first game well it looks
like Hikaru starting with white despite
uh him being cool
talking great hair quality Hikaru looks
slick gotta say hi but uh yeah we're off
it's uh E4 E5 it's a Spanish Mo I'm
guessing just judging but from recent
history between these two but uh okay
actually wow Hikaru is black we got that
one a bit wrong so I was gonna say if a
car route starts with the white pieces
he has the advantage but no it's the
Italian game this is what Wesley has
been going to it's his go-to opening of
course we saw him on the black side of
this opening uh in the last game between
him and uh Arjun but yeah this has still
been seen before between these two uh
Giants and really interesting here that
Wesley actually switches it up now he
played the Spanish against Arjun when he
started with the white pieces and now he
starts with the Italian because he's
pretty clear hikaru's been watching that
match so Hikaru would have been prepared
to face that he goes to the Italian but
of course that said Italian is no big
surprise for Hikaru that is another
opening that he was expecting very
important that this is just a two-game
match so once again the result of this
is going to be critical Hikaru will try
to neutralize uh Wesley's advantage of
having the white pieces and look at this
he goes for a very Dynamic idea of
hitting that F2 weakness moves this king
sidesteps with the king and the whole
plan for black here is to get that F5
break in David you want to strike in the
center you want to open it up with F5
one gets the feeling Kaya you were
asking what has Hikaru been up to so far
this morning I think he's been looking
at this line okay and this is really
positive for us as fans because Wesley
first of all avoided the Spanish
therefore avoiding the Berlin Wall
therefore avoiding a quick draw so he's
showing his aggressive intentions he
wants to win with white and Hikaru
avoiding what he went for two days ago
against Wesley this uh maybe solid but
passive approach we did which did lead
to a couple of drawers I'm slightly
surprised to see the Black Knight
retreat in this in this fashion I
thought it was going back another way
just to show Tanya's point there black
did have a very aggressive approach
available to him if he had retreated the
Knight to a different Square it does
look odd we say Knights on the rim are
dim this Knight can also be eliminated
by a white Bishop but that will come
with the custom of the bishop pair the
most important idea here is to throw
this Pawn forward blast open a file
because uh we've talked about this
bishop in the previous game same opening
remember this bishop extremely stronger
than that on the diagonal so why not
open up a rook towards this Target on F2
as well and this would be a very
committal decision Hikaru says no he
goes back in the other direction and
after Wesley develops don't be surprised
if Hikaru at some point moves this
Knight again just to get that pawn
moving getting the Rook motoring behind
it but now it's back to a more
maneuvering battle perhaps after this
last couple of turns but it feels like
white was handed a couple free turns
right because you went Knight out to G4
and then Knight back H3 that pawn push
for weight is a movie you want to play
anyway a black put the king in the
corner to play F5 and now can't play F5
because the knight's in the way so this
seems like something went wrong for
icaro in the opening not that he's that
much worse in the current position but
even his facial expression was like huh
what's going on here and he didn't go
for the most testing at least the most
tactical possibility and said he drops
back and Wesley should be slightly
better The Rook on A2 later can slide
even towards the center or you can
double on the queen side if you feel
that you can open up the position I like
the start of this game for Wesley so
yeah and one thematic plan would be to
drop the White Knight back and reroute
it to a very solid Square in front of
the white king looks uh really nice for
what you've got to say Hikaru if he has
slipped up in the in the move order in
the opening he would just be like the
rest of us the number of times I've
messed up the move order in the Italian
game from the white side from the black
side I mean I can't count it's just too
many it's so hard to understand all
these little differences these little
nuances but uh looks good for Wesley he
has dropped his Knight back it's a bit
strange to see because the cargo made
his intention so clear with that king
move and the Knight jumped forward that
he wanted to blast open with that F Pawn
but then coming in the way of his own
plan with this nitrate Retreat slightly
strange decisions there and now he takes
a think now you were mentioning this is
a thematic idea what black also can do
in these positions is to challenge that
light squared Bishop that white has on
C4 making a developing move himself
Bishop to E6 because what you really
want to do what you wanted to do with
that pawn push that we were talking
about is open up the f file so at the
cost stuff even doubling up your pawns
let's say after that Bishop trade David
if the bishop was to land on E6 and
white was to trade these Bishops you're
happy with the spawn structure because
you managed to open up that file yep
your Rook is open and you do have extra
Central support these pawns might look a
bit ugly they might look a bit weak long
term but for now they control all of
these Central squares so uh that will be
the most logical move in this position I
feel but uh slightly inconsistent
perhaps with his previous few turns and
uh Hikaru thinking the time issue not so
drastic yet but he needs to come up with
a plan if not going for this bishop
trade he might well find himself cramped
I don't see what else he would be doing
here I think I understand where hakara
went wrong we're talking about uh kind
of subtleties in the opening and when we
make inaccuracies if we just go back to
the moment uh before Wesley went before
just very quickly a very common move is
that night going up to A3 instead of the
pawn push to B4 and now after Knight G4
white has to slide The Rook up to E2
defend the F2 on and the King slides the
corn like hikard in the game and after
H3 I'm pretty sure there's a move F5 so
tactically it's just a wild position and
I think that this is in preparation
still where black gets the open file and
creates an attack so I think that Hikaru
maybe mixed up his lines didn't realize
that once uh Wesley pushed the pawn on
the queen side it opened up the second
rank for his other Rook his more a
passive rook and that is what has led
Wesley to get the upper hand in the
opening because the car had to backtrack
it wasn't the end of the world but it's
a clear Plus in my eyes in my estimation
for Wesley so yeah definitely and it
looks vaguely symmetrical right now
especially with these Knights these two
proud Black Knights mirroring the white
counterparts but this black king in the
corner isn't necessarily that well
placed and uh White is the first one to
break in the center either now or maybe
on the next move first you could uh just
slide back with your Bishop make sure
there's no attacks against it this is a
very typical idea I've had it in myself
plenty times against farrugia for
example but uh next white will just
occupy the center and what does black do
in the meantime the reason I say the
black king isn't actually well placed in
the corner it's because you want to
centralize your Rook you often want to
move your Rook here but suddenly this
Pawn would be loose so it feels like not
just as Hikaru lost two moves but he's
given white moves for free he's given
white uh plenty of options and okay
Wesley doesn't go for that instead he
brings his Queen to this to the square
highlighting the fact that this F7 Pawn
isn't defended sufficiently
are there other plan that we were
talking about has also been snatched
away from Hikaru no more neutralizing
this light Square Bishop by offering a
trade the queen on B3 doesn't only hit
the F7 Pawn but also stops any of future
trade or development well one of the
things that black can do to insist on
that is move the queen One Step Ahead
Queen to E7 you defend that F7 Pawn
you're also in the future wanting to
really trade off these Bishops because
it is the key in White's position it is
really one of the strongest minor pieces
that white has so Bishop E6 has to I
feel uh David uh arrived on the board at
some point yeah this does however give
Wesley one move to open up to control
the center and this would be slightly
awkward for black potentially uh yes you
can still offer a trade but maybe some
different consequences he can't
retrieves as a different Square let's
wait to see the uh The Fallout from that
one but it looks like the same idea it's
the same idea but a nice subtlety
because I just realized that after Queen
E7 there was a nasty little move that
white had which could be the knight jump
to F5 you hit that Queen on E7 and
usually black wants to trade these
Knights but take a look at the position
that we have Bishop F5 EF5 and now
because of the King on on the Square
that it is the queen on the Square that
it is the Knight on G6 is actually
trapped you can't jump it to F4 because
then white just picks up that Knight and
watch out for that pin along the E file
you can't recapture it and I think
that's why Precision here by Hikaru
choosing the E8 Square yeah very nice so
he's created an Escape Route for his
Knight also hinting that he might throw
this Pawn forward to try and trap this
white Bishop I wouldn't be surprised
though if Wesley either takes the time
out to prevent that idea by uh pushing
his Pawn forward allowing on passant if
B5 ever happens or goes for a central
break Let's uh allow Wesley some time to
think of that decision uh how about you
guys I know the Italian game is maybe
the opening I struggle with most in
terms of memory in terms of
understanding the ideas uh what are your
least favorite openings the one says
them and the French defense I had those
ready I thought I'd make you pause for
thought
why why don't you like those openings
actually the London system for the same
reason uh I think maybe David in the
Italian because if we look at the
current position not a single piece has
been traded not one and so you're kind
of just maneuvering around trying to
find the best squares and then you don't
know is it too soon to push a pawn is
that going to create a weakness and
Wesley did just push his pawn and this
was just trying to open up the board for
his pieces he is a bit ahead in terms of
space and development uh but that's why
I don't like the London the French your
Bishop is terrible it's buried behind uh
the pawns the light score Bishop for
black is just a miserable piece and I
can never back the French defense even
though yes I have played it before I use
it against Vision on it I feel like the
Italian I don't mind playing against it
but the London I absolutely hate and the
reason for that is that I think it's the
kind of opening that you don't expect
will ever be dangerous for you but then
somehow it always goes wrong I have the
worst score against London I probably
shouldn't be seeing this
future opponents are preparing right now
all right well you did see something
cool on the screen uh just now the
tournament trophy uh every tournament
will have a look at that how nice is
that every tournament will have a unique
nft trophy by a unique artist and you
can actually get this trophy it's up for
bidding on chesschamps.io or you can use
the QR code scan that with your phone
and go in and make your bed for that
very cool trophy wait so I can bid for
the show yeah it looks like it's from
the new Harry Potter game or something
yeah it looks really cool like the
Quidditch cup
Harry Potter fan uh Loosely not really
okay okay like the try wizard trophy
that's the one oh sorry yesterday was
Pokemon today
over there oh yeah
I think everyone knows that now yeah
yeah if you haven't really that's on you
if you haven't read Harry Potter exactly
right if you haven't seen or read Harry
Potter by now well
you should was it in the first book that
they had to play a chess game to yeah
yeah it was and Magnus Carlsen remembers
uh every move in that just came we
tested him in that one we tested him and
I would I just put a position on the
board I was like what's this from and he
guessed it was Harry Potter and he was
like okay the Knight moved here that
means the Knight must be Ron uh the
queen you know must be this one and
Harry must have been the bishop to
deliver Checkmate yeah another level of
uh brainy yeah yeah not the level of
memory wizard chess and is there
anything magical about this position
that we are seeing right now after 18
moves in the first game here I'm not
sure magical's the one but uh at least
Wesley's gaining space pushing forward
with his pawns I slightly prefer the
right position uh what about you guys
sir I think yes White House space but
that's so typical and classical of uh
the Italian opening that white does
manage to get this control over the
center we see it also in Spanish that
white has the space Advantage what black
really wants to do to neutralize that is
exactly what Hikaru is doing try and
trade off as many pieces the last pieces
on the board the less you'll feel
cramped because when you're behind on
Space you don't have that much those
many squares to jump around with your
own Army so you really want to try and
minimize that feel that lack of well not
having fresh air at least on the board
and look at this last move of Hikaru
hinting at exactly that he moves the
bishop as well out of the way and wants
to get a rook trade-in as well
if those Rooks leave the board on the
open a file I don't feel that Wesley has
enough ammunition to really cause
problems for Hikaru yeah it definitely
feels like every trade that happens the
closer black gets towards the desired
result towards equality uh do you see
anything here Robert that Wesley can try
to keep some tension keep some hopes I
think he's gonna have to trade at least
one pair of rocks along the a file and
maybe he's gonna have to go after the C7
Pawn as Queen is in line with that pawn
uh the F7 Pawn we've talked about
because the king steps at the corner
that means The Rook needs to stay with
its attention on it so it's gonna be a
fight for the only open file Rooks need
open lines it's about that a file so if
Wesley can make use of that he should be
the side and with the advantage I also
like that his Queen is the more active
of the two but I just want to give
hikara some credit really quickly
because he slipped in the opening I
really do think that he misremembered
his lines not that it was a too terrible
a position but it was worse for him and
he just makes these good moves quickly
after that so I I'm very impressed by
the way this position has churned from
one clearly better for Wesley to just
kind of like this might be a handshake
soon yeah at least a small strategic
threat potentially of capturing a pawn
because for example if black plays a
lazy move a quiet move uh actually maybe
not that one but after a trade of Pawns
then suddenly white could double up the
black pawns on the B file by capturing
this bishop the reason I say not that
one is because suddenly actually the
black queen is quite well placed and
queen trade would be uh comfortable here
for black it's just really weird I
always find it awkward as well in this
opening how were the Knights just stare
down at each other it's never clear
which one you can move it's like a kind
of stare off between them I can't move
my Knights because my pawns might drop
you can't move your Knights because your
pawns might drop and it's just uh yeah
they cancel each other out so in this
position not too much to worry about for
black but with this last move Bishop to
E3 as you're pointing out in this
current position at least white Knights
are just slightly slightly better than
Black's Knights and the reason I say
that is David because look at that F5
Square the White Knight can actually
jump to that square and because the
light Square Bishops have been traded
off there is no piece to chat challenge
that meanwhile uh black snide on G6
doesn't have that freedom it doesn't
have that flexibility yet to arrive on
F4 because of that Bishop in E3 which is
why I think the bishop trades in the
line that you were pointing at uh would
actually be great for black because then
black also gets the option to jump in
with the Knight and I like your idea of
putting that Queen on C8 just a it's a
strange move and a strange Square
because you're also giving up the a file
at some point but it's sort of
prophylactic it's it's looking into the
future and saying you know what this is
what you want but on my terms yeah I I
must uh admit hit Tanya I was showing
this as an example of a bad movement and
suddenly I accidentally stumbled across
maybe one of the most logical and uh
yeah exactly Hikaru Nakamura here he's
got a bunch of options you can't move
this Rook because it's tied down
defending a pawn you don't really want
to move these Knights you don't want to
move your Bishop you could make an
argument for moving the king back but
then you feel a bit silly having lost a
couple of moves uh having put it in the
corner earlier so process of elimination
this is what I do a lot in chess if I
don't know what to look for uh then I
just looked at all my pieces I talked to
you no none of you can move apart from
the queen so I'm expecting the queen uh
to get busy and maybe just slide across
you could make an argument for jumping
in but uh okay Hikaru goes all the way
back with this queen where she came from
very solid square and uh just very solid
position for both
and the reason that he's done that is
because the queen from here is actually
eyeing that B Pawn as well so right now
all these trades that we were pointing
out the queen on it will do a good job
of not only hitting the B5 Pawn but also
the central E4 Pawn so a nice square and
once again the ball is in Wesley's Court
Robert what do you do you trade off on
E5 hoping to get the Bishops off and try
and Destroy Black's Pawn structure I
feel like Wesley's the type of player
who just Maneuvers around a bunch he
finds just little improving move it's
kind of carpovian anatolic the former
world champion was well regarded
visibility in very locked positions just
to reroute his pieces so I feel like
Wesley he thrives in that situation if
he feels like he has absolutely nothing
he can just swap the pieces off and say
I'm ever so slightly better take that as
a bit of a mental Edge but I do feel
like this position is so solid for
Hikaru he made this last from Queen d8
he's just shiring up his position and as
Tanya said eyeing that B5 Pawn in in
case the White Queen is any funny idea
so I don't really see too much in the
way of an advantage for white anymore
with the liquidation with the pieces
getting traded I think that makes
hikaru's task more and more simple yeah
I just love what Hikaru has done he's
defended everything he's just locked
things down he's uh especially with this
last move he said okay no threats for
you no promising captions for you you
find a plan you burn time on the clock
trying to solve all these problems or at
least trying to create something out of
nothing and I'll just sit here happily
wait for you to make that decision and
then I'll pounce and then I'll counter
if you go wrong and that's why he wins
so many Blitz rapid tournaments and
that's why he's so good at speech as
Hikaru because he nearly never blunders
but he always pounces when he gets a
chance and he gets these positions where
he's ready to react it's a very reactive
style but uh very effective Style
remember you can always reach us either
on Twitter using the hashtag chess
Champs or in the twitch chat I see a
bunch of comments coming in super nice
to see that if you do have any questions
for excellent experts here in the studio
then share them on Twitter or in the
twitch chat and we'll bring up as many
as we can
you know we've been discussing in this
position the idea of White's night
actually jumping forward and I think
that is something that black needs to
watch out for but first Wesley decides
to sidestep with the queen to be for and
is he perhaps hinting at some kind of a
pawn at once all the way up to C4 and
then to C5 trying to block that Bishop
are there any tactical ideas along the
A3 f8 diagonal I can you know one can
get the feeling that something is being
set up here yeah something's being set
up but it's very mysterious I've got to
say uh Tanya and he played that move
Wesley he kind of leaned back shook his
head frowned for a second and then
recomposed himself
yeah I'm curious what the idea is as
well and maybe just positioning his
Queen on a slightly better Square where
it covers the dark squares
um you mentioned this idea of pushing
white supawns forward that's on the
cards certainly but Hikaru just
solidifies things even further he's like
a rock right now uh how are you going to
erode this structure for black how are
you going to break him down
now I wouldn't want to have this
position as white uh wanting to win uh
of course Wesley's not in that must win
situation but
your car is so solid you called him a
rock so he's like Onyx is what you're
saying you need to find the water just
trying to get through here but I see
nothing I mean that moved Knight D7 it
makes sure that all of the bases are
covered some of the earlier variations
we're talking about whereas with a trait
of the dark Square Bishops blacks Queen
Side Pawn structure could be shattered
now the 997 also protects that Bishop
just in case and we see Wesley he moves
his Knight back as well and that's the
benefit of his position he has a little
bit more space that Knight heading up
the board to C4 a knight on D7 it's
dominated by a pawn three squares away I
love to make mention of it and it
actually is important here that white is
just a teeny bit more active Tanya had
been focusing on the night on G3 which
still can land on F5 at any given moment
but that night on it wasn't F3 slides
back to D2 up to C4 and maybe that's the
small benefit of Wesley's position the
small little nagging advantage that will
cause hikar some trouble oh Knight's
jumping all over the board look at that
last move Hikari says you go back with
the Knight I come forward with mine
Knight to H4 yeah I'm not sure exactly
what that does but it does it does scare
us a little bit it does scare us a
little bit and it does deter this idea
of knights F5 that will simply be traded
off I just love how uh Wesley's moved
the queen B4 move earlier vacated this
C4 Square really mysterious but the idea
was two or three moves uh two or three
players we say uh just in the future the
Knight now leaping forward I'm expecting
Wesley to play that very quickly why not
and uh at least pose a question to
Hikaru uh here it's like Onyx bind bind
just create that bind and uh yeah
hopefully uh from Wesley point of view
you don't allow black to break out but
uh of course Hikaru will be waiting for
that punch like Hitmonchan and just
ready to uh too many Pokemon I'll stop
that now but uh he'll be waiting to
break out punch his way out of this one
if given the opportunity may be the idea
he didn't get it in earlier remember he
wants to play for F5 but uh maybe it's
on the cards either now or on the next
few moves I would love to see F5 on the
board we've been talking about it since
the start of the game and even if it
comes now it will have big questions to
Wesley how is he going to respond in the
center if this Pawn break comes through
and knowing Hikaru he's not going to shy
away from it that is exactly what he's
thinking about the pawn move all the way
up to squares hitting that E4 pawn and
Wesley about five minutes and things are
getting tricky Kaya oh but talking about
big questions we have a great question
on the Twitter from Matt asking you guys
have the commentators played each other
before Oh we did actually just a couple
of days
but have you played in like a tournament
or something like that no no either of
you no really have you guys played
against me no no wow okay I've I haven't
played in the US that much I must say an
Isle of Man and Grand Swiss we played in
the same tournament I think we even sat
two boards apart once but uh no not
against each other we Dodge each other
that's why we remain on such good terms
we need to make that happen or should we
avoid it
you know I don't play very much so I'm
happy to not play chess but I think that
both Wesley I mean look at this position
that we just had we actually had a huge
change because after the move F5 Wesley
took that pawn a car did not take back
he said brings his Queen out and now the
question is will hikar just regain that
pawn will he be fine here uh but I think
that Wesley he has an opportunity as a
tactical shot look at that Knight on H4
they say loose pieces drop off there's a
queen on B4 and there are many pieces in
a row on that fourth rank but if that
Knight takes the bishop first we're
about to see the line clear out that the
Knight takes back for black and then you
push the pawn up to D5 that Knight on H4
is under attack the Knight on B6 is
under attack from the bishop things are
getting spicy wow that's great full
board Vision I've got to say Roberts and
uh it's not visually obvious at first so
it might take Wesley some time to spot
but this is really annoying this Knight
is hit of course it can step back and
recatch the pawn regain the material
balance but after a bunch of Trades I'm
not sure which one you take first but
for example just this line suddenly
white is the only one who can win
because you have the superior structure
also in positions where it's just major
Pieces Just the heavy pieces such as
queens and Rooks Pawn shelter is all
important and for example white hair can
centralize defending this key F2 Pawn
from any threats you have more shelter
than the opponent therefore you have the
advantage also easy Targets on the queen
side this is really really sneaky stuff
Robert and if he finds it it feels like
Hikaru is on the back foot Wesley will
play a risk-free position his dream uh
the style of Chess he loves to play and
uh he might well get close to that win I
don't think Hikaru will be loving his
position if that is played but it's very
difficult to see that you can kind of
clear the whole fourth rank in one blue
and will he find it
and then to be able to also evaluate at
that last position that we had on the
board really offers big chances because
let's not forget guys that actually the
next game Hikaru starts with the white
pieces so if this one ends in a draw
with everything being traded off and
white isn't able to find something big
in that position to really fight for uh
Hikaru well one he can easily take it to
to the Armageddon something that Wesley
wants to avoid and there we have it
Robert your idea on the board so Wesley
not only having great oh the car missed
it look in a car's face
he looked to the side he was oh what is
that and he realizes that now he is
going to face a terrible ending while
Queen and Rooks on the board but a
horrible Pawn structure that was a
missed shot from hikara yeah huge Miss
and uh we're going to end up in that
position we predicted and it's only
white who can win just take those
Knights off the board I'm not sure if
you have anything better here but uh
just lock it down it's all about white
in that position more active Queen more
active Rook better Pawn structure safer
King and uh if you're Wesley so you will
hope that all of those things add up to
an advantage of course the material is
disappearing from the board the drawing
margins will be quite high in general
but uh it's all about Wesley so and
Hikaru he was shocked but he's
recomposed himself this is another thing
that sets him apart at the very top of
World Chess him Magnus Carlsen Wesley
they all recover from setbacks so
quickly even if they miss a move they
recover and they just continue playing
chess he's so adaptive to this
situations and we have spoken about that
before that's one of his biggest Trends
is just how resourceful he is he doesn't
really dwell on what's happened for too
long that little headshake that we saw
in that said he's done with it he's
ready for this new position this new
challenge but very impressive by Wesley
to spot this idea Robert that you were
mentioning especially the geometry of
the Knight hanging on H4 and you call
this action out it is on the board uh
there's one thing that works in Black's
favor is that the queen on F5 and The
Rook on f8 they do I the F2 Pawn as well
as the other Central Pawn which is a
weakness so black also has a few trumps
the one thing that black needs to watch
out for in this position with White
Queen centralized imagine if the Rook
joins the attack goes all the way to the
seventh rank Rook coming into E7
threatening a mate in one on G7 and you
don't want to allow that yeah so there
is at least one thread on the board as
Tanya points out you don't have time to
for example push a pawn because White's
record will land and um of course the
Checkmate threat but also Targets on the
other flank so I'm expecting Hikaru to
do something quite energetic here not
sure exactly what to be honest but uh he
needs to do something now the other
Potential Threat will be taking his Pawn
if the black queen moves away and uh
yeah I wouldn't like to be Hikaru he's
looking really really calm uh it's like
that Taylor Swift song just shake it off
and uh he's looking really relaxed but I
would be panicking I've got to say
that's black it looks fantastic for a
white because a queen trade that won't
solve all of Black's problems either the
pawn structure is so bad that white may
be able to pick off the pawns or tie
Black's Rook down in a resulting end
game to the defense of those pawns that
is not what you want so that's what
hikar was thinking about meanwhile with
the Queens remaining on the board it
wasn't my step up with his Rook yes
rookie seven is an idea but he can bring
his work to E6 he can bring it up to E4
pushes Pawn F2 to F3 and just cement the
position there are no weaknesses in
White's Camp so I think this is super
unpleasant to play at the highest level
because Wesley so he typically punishes
people against our generic guide seat
there was one mistake by Arjun down the
stretch of the end game he made Argent
pay the full price that full point was
Wesley's that's the reason he's here
facing a car yeah and he would go on
down I was gonna say I love it Robert
just either one of these drug moves
rookie four rookie six uh Tanya which
one would you be I was think about the
third one about the idea that we were
talking about coming in for the mating
threat with rookie seven but I think
what Hikaru has in mind is to challenge
that Rook you don't want it to stay
alive for too long bring that Rook up to
F7 stop that mate offer a rook trade and
this is how he plans to defend this
position if the Rooks do get traded
after Rook F7 the queen picks it up
White Queen can pick up a Pawn on the
left side of the board but then black
gets a Central Pawn and everything is
under control and I was just thinking
you're absolutely right that the Hikaru
looks like he has in fact shaken it off
as you said because he believes that
Haters Gonna Hate and players gonna play
he's feeling 22. uh just like the age of
quieter today oh yes thank you oh hi I'm
the problem it's me so you know we can
all throw on our t-swift references but
this just looks great for Wesley I mean
there's no risk whatsoever whether he
wins this game is another question but
he can push his pawns he can bring his
King up uh the thing about this is that
white is essentially up a pawn black has
two BB pawns those both of them are
stopped by one white Pawn on B5 that's
why we typically don't like double pawns
they're not the end of the world early
stages but in the end game it's like
you're just down upon despite the
material equality so this is what Wesley
is hoping for to move his pawns forward
bring his King up but will it be enough
because as soon as you push your pawns
your king gets exposed to a bunch of
checks and the black king is tucked away
in the corner yeah and we should also
mention that Wesley can't try and Bully
Hikaru here with a threat of a queen
exchange if the Queen's ever disappear
white will be winning King opponent
games because this Robert mentioned that
structure for black there's two I was
gonna say two become one they don't
really become one those two are canceled
out by the one uh on the B file so uh
definitely all about Wesley here can he
finish it off can he convert this
extremely difficult but uh he'll be
loving his position this is right up his
alley as we mentioned
um this is Wesley so's uh wheelhouse
this is what he loves to do just grind
down his opponents in risk-free
positions
very impressive it was looking super
drawish just uh not too long ago and
Wesley has been yeah look at the bar
here
if you'd asked me to guess five moves
for black David I would not have thought
about G5 in that position no me neither
I've got to admit and uh okay the
evaluation bus stays there meaning that
White's Advantage is actually long term
that black made oh then it drops so
maybe Matt Black made a tactical mistake
but Wesley didn't pounce on it
immediately I'm not sure exactly what
that was maybe it was some way to try
and force the Queens off the board but I
didn't spot it Wesley didn't spot it and
both players are around the two minute
Mark now so we might see those
occasional swings but Queen end games
Precision is so difficult every move
white will have 10 possible Queen moves
but uh often only one of them will be
strong so from a human point of view
extremely hard to Guess that and okay he
gives a couple of Tricks White Queen is
centralized as well that's what you want
in Queen nine games look at the White
Queen she controls the whole board The
Black Queen very passive only
controlling a few squares so so
Advantage weight but not winning yet
it's going to take a lot of work and I'm
gonna ask you guys put you guys on a
spot too predict the result right now in
this one
I choose the one that you don't choose
Robert I'll let you have the first first
pick and pick a draw I think that the
yeah I think the white king will be a
little bit too exposed because what
Wesley wants to do is create a pass Pawn
we've talked about this if you cut the
board you look at this various pawns the
three the two pawns for black on the B
file stop by one white pod the F2 Pawn
which is right next to the king it can
push two squares forward but as soon as
you do that your king becomes vulnerable
to checks from the other side and we see
that Hikaru he brings his Queen back a
square going after the pawn on D5 so
it's hard for white to both defend that
pawn and allow himself to push his F
Pawn forward so I just don't think he
has enough in this position to get a win
yeah I'll go for a win for white but uh
relax
uh yeah we'll see I do believe in
Wesley's conversion chances against
anyone in the world other than maybe
Magnus Carlson and Hikaru Nakamura and
that's the uh that's the kind of really
uh Elite uh competition he has to face
here that he has to break down
these really yeah incredible Heights the
aster scale but first he's offering a
queen trade and you have to say no if
you're Hikaru Nakamura I think because
white support structure is superior
queen and king opponent games will favor
white you have to say no but also you
have to be careful where you move that
Queen to uh David because just imagine
you know you want to give a check on
that Central Square so you decide you
know what I'm just gonna sidestep it all
the way to G7 so I can land on E5 next
and guess what happens then it's just a
meet in one with Queen F5 that would be
game over so of course Hikaru knows what
he's doing he declines the queen trade
very important Point Robert you made
earlier that all kingpong endings are or
at least should be winning for White and
the Queens have to stay on the board
Queenie 8 also comes in with the idea of
centralizing it to E5 and that's kind of
a square you want it on yeah I suddenly
see Robert being very interested in this
position for white it looks like some
nasty Queen checks essentially yeah I'm
just trying to see like can I somewhat
offer Queen trade uh but if the King
goes if you're Queen E6 it's one of the
ideas I'm trying to figure out the
Queens are swapped then I was feeling
like black wins this Pawn on E6 but
maybe even though black is going up upon
a material white is going to still be
the side with the advantage because you
go F4 this is crazy you take it we King
takes back you take on E6 black goes up
a pawn but is actually losing your extra
Pawn is on the D file white has the
outside Pawn it's a distraction the
black king will have to scoot over the
white king will swoop in win first the
d-pawn then the both of the B pawns and
win the game that's how end games often
go with just king of Pawns yeah and
actually those B pawns they're basically
the same as one it's on the board wow
okay Wesley so banking on this King of
Porn game being winning Hikaru is going
to have to calculate really well here he
did he did he dodged it and I think he
was right to do so so still very solid
for black still defending this Pawn
hinting and jumping in with some counter
checks can Wesley win his Queen is
getting in now wow this one it feels
like it should be really promising but
uh not quite winning yet for Wesley so
and both players now under at the minute
Mark around 40 seconds each this one is
going to be a race can Hikaru hold it's
not going to be easy for him it really
feels like it's hanging by a thread for
black and Hikaru absolutely precise here
declines the queen trade the fact that
he could one upon in the King Pawn
ending and still it would be lost goes
on to show that no matter what he cannot
afford to trade queens and there Wesley
not repeating with the check but now it
just feels like a karus queen has
managed to get active
yeah and as soon as White's Queen gets
greedy and starts taking some pawns on
the wrong flank on the queen side The
Black Queen will have all the time in
the world to deliver a bunch of Nazi
check uh Nazi checks so it looks like we
might get a repetition we might get a
job check check check draw yeah second
time we see in that position okay Wesley
plays on this is promising that's what
we'd like to see he's looking for his
chances he drops the queen back Hikaru
has to be careful where he puts the
black king if the black king lands on
the wrong Square we could see a queen
exchange on White's terms so Hikaru is
still with some questions to answer what
could be a wrong Square
um if the king comes forward on maybe
onto the f file shifts towards the
center at some point you've got to time
it right but the White Queen
why oh like now oh could you have
swapped Queens though oh yeah saw it
immediately and he's shot oh my unless
we've got to show that draw they've
repeated the position three times did
Wesley have a win on that final move
just before he agreed the draw I'm gonna
check this but both players seem to miss
that white could have traded off the
queens and Hikaru reacted Wesley could
have won it's confirmed he could have
won if you didn't trade the Queens off
what the final move was it blunder by
Wesley so and Wesley so has not reacted
we saw a big reaction on Hikaru rushing
off but it is a draw do you think Wesley
knows he had a win here I mean as soon
as the game ends and you see the game
analysis he knows it was winning but
yeah you know it looks like he's just
trying to keep himself composed and
Wesley is second to none at doing that
I'm just waiting for the reaction I feel
like that's it right he knows it yeah
he's just keeping a poker face right now
he doesn't want to give it away and
there we have it that was the moment
that was hikaru's Reaction game one in
the loser final ends with a draw Hikaru
Nakamura will have the white pieces in
the second game David show us what was
this I'm so shocked Kaya because just as
an instructor's point I was saying don't
allow a queen trade that's the only way
you lose this position is black and
Hikaru
he just missed it and uh Wesley so
trusted him Wesley so didn't even look
to try and punish his opponent and it
was in this position it's still a draw
the position has almost repeated itself
a few times and Hikaru maybe relaxed one
move too early he brought his King to
the f file and Caillou asking this
question how can we win this game that's
by trading Queens Robert's mentioned it
before any Queen end game uh any king of
porno game sorry once the Queen's
disappear is winning for white and white
could have simply move the queen across
this is a pin the Queens are
disappearing from the board and there's
no way to save this one for black if the
Queens come off the white king is first
to reach the center and next move you
create a poor majority on the king side
you have three versus two and it's an
easy win black could try and spin that
in a few different ways try to defend
but it would have been helpless hopeless
he would have lost the game so just one
move by Wesley so offering that Queen
trade would have won the game instead he
repeated with a check and it was a draw
this weekend
this whole concept of just bulldozing
the black king jumping in there with the
queen and making sure the Rook comes in
with a ladder mate is everything this
chapter is about everything this chapter
is about
the point is I don't want you to get a
move that's not in the course and go I
don't know what to do
percent of games
the addition white is winning about 60
70 of the time and I think if you learn
these lines that very easily could be 75
or 80 for you
[Music]
drama drama drama it's day four in the
area of things Monsters game two the
final rapid game between Hikaru and
Wesley is coming up very shortly if
you're not a subscriber here is a twitch
break
[Music]
whoa Wesley so could have taken the lead
but it ends with a draw dramatic yeah
absolutely dramatic
I'm completely unexpected as well I mean
I did wonder why hikara's reaction and
maybe
on a mouse lip but we'll find out now uh
later on but uh talking about drama
that's not being the only drama because
there has been many exciting things
happening in division two and division
three aha so starting with division two
the Winner's uh portion
Fabiano faced off against you Yang Yi
and we you know the first game went for
fabi's way you know he just paid
excellent chess and game three actually
saw a little bit of a turnaround because
you Yang Yi kind of switched his tactics
and he really started to push Fabiana
caruana right to the edge and just when
it was looking promising he made a
critical mistake and you know you cannot
make a mistake against these 28 2700
super Grand Masters and that was it his
tournament is over and uh well like he's
going to the nudism bracket I forgot
about double elimination but Fabiana
caruana he is on top of the winners
bracket and uh sadly we're ready for the
Grand Final Fabiano carono yeah he is
ready for the Grand Final and uh sadly
we also had to say goodbye to Vladimir
bid too low in the Armageddon and found
himself with two little times yeah the
winner of the vision two will qualify
for division one and event two there's
also a big Grand Final going on today in
division three pragnananda and some
Savion is it finished no they're still
playing their fourth game but I mean
there it was just insane I have to say
first game was just wild I haven't seen
a game like that ever but in second game
with the black pieces Sam Savion just
struck back with such powerful chess and
uh the third game was very tense very
cagey very long drawn out and now
they're playing game four and anything
can happen wow wow wow what a cool day
upstairs in the air things Masters game
two final rapid game and the losers
final between Wesley and Hikaru is
coming up in just a few minutes
we're off it's the Italian game this is
what Wesley has been going to it's his
go-to opening I do feel like this
position is so solid for Hikaru and
there we have it the car missed it look
at a car's face he looked to the side he
was oh what is that and he realizes that
now he is going to face a terrible
ending while Queen and Rooks on the
board but a horrible Pawn structure that
was a missed shot from hikara
wow what is your reaction to just how
that game ended Robert whoa sturdy
defense for a car for a very long time
so for Wesley he didn't have too much
time remaining I feel like he thought
the draw was inevitable but that's why
you never stop calculating for Wesley he
should have paused hey Carl realized
that only after his move it could have
emit a mouse slip but you need to make
the most of your changes because they
don't come often against a car in
Nakamura so if you would have paused for
only 5-10 seconds would he have seen it
do you think absolutely because the king
and the queen were in the same line he
could offered the queen trade he knew
the king of pawning games are good for
him I think he just thought the draw was
in the bag and he just said let's go to
game two wow it's gonna be game two it
is best attitude here on the losers
bracket so if we have a winner in this
game then that player will make it
through to tomorrow's Grand Final to
face off against Magnus Carlsen if it is
a draw then this match will be decided
in Armageddon and Tonya now Hikaru
Nakamura will have the white pieces what
should we expect from game two okay I'm
still thinking about what we just said I
am absolutely shocked it's your birthday
but that Hikaru literally just gifted
the game to uh Wesley in one move and
Wesley just declined the gift instead he
just repeated I can't believe it I've
never seen anything like that and now
this just means not only fighting Hikaru
with the black pieces but also fighting
your own mind yeah because Wesley knows
what he missed and that's gonna be hard
to overcome how mentally hard is that
David it's incredibly hard I was
praising these players for shaking it
off forgetting things but that was
elementary stuff that was uh that will
play on both their minds for sure and
now I think the big question is is
Hikaru after recovering from that shock
is he going to play a real game or are
we going to get another Berlin draw are
we going to go straight to Armageddon to
decide it just give those players uh a
bit more time to recover to relax and I
do feel that has been hikaru's strategy
throughout the tournament he's done it
twice both against Wesley and Magnus and
I think it's likely again just uh it
would be understandable very
understandable here just because uh yeah
he needs to get over that one moment
that one movement yeah we did hear
Wesley predict that before the match
started that Hikaru would try to go for
the Armageddon is that what you think as
well Robert I can not to pull a Charles
Barkley but I guarantee it I think that
Karen Nakamura he does it for the fans
he wants this to go to Armageddon he
thinks it's good content Wesley so not
even at the board right now and he just
sits back and I think we will see that
Berlin repetition
okay so uh blinking you miss it this one
might be over soon and we should be five
on the board it's happening guys it's
going to happen but I think this time
probably Wesley's had a shift in his
mind and there it is David it is on the
board the check and back and check and
back and checking back and that's it
yo-yo between the queens and it's over
we have a draw we're going to Armageddon
we are going to armaged on you guys and
we do love that game two is a uh super
quick uh draw between Hikaru and Wesley
and that means 10 minutes they're now
gonna make their bids and decide this
match in Armageddon wow okay so we're
not surprised
that is kind of fun though it's your
birthday wish yeah you wanted Armageddon
we get Armageddon yes we do all right so
what what do you expect now Robert now
they're gonna start thinking about their
bids what will be the bids from these
two now I think Hikaru is gonna go lower
than he did against Magnus because uh
Wesley he's gonna see that match he
really wants the black pieces he hasn't
struggled against a car over the board I
mean he's never really had a
disadvantage but you don't want to go
too low so he was talking eight and a
half minutes Hikaru is so dangerous and
yesterday with white against Magnus he
really did almost make Magnus pay he
went down to the wire so I think that
hikar really really wants black but West
has to be careful not to go too low on
the clock do you agree Tanya they both
want the black pieces a hundred percent
and it is all about once again finding
that balance with the clock and wanting
the black pieces because you also don't
want to get flagged you need to have
enough time whoever is the player who
does play with white is definitely going
to do everything to have a storm on the
board so you want that time to be able
to overcome those difficult questions
once again because this was such a quick
draw I think for Wesley to overcome what
happened in game one is also something
he needs to fight a little still he
mentioned at the start Kaya that he
doesn't he would prefer to not take it
to the Armageddon but I think after what
we just saw he's also sort of fine with
it because he kind of didn't want to
fight that game too much with the black
pieces Hikaru was sticking to his
strategy he doesn't care he he's got a
tunnel vision on this the man comes with
a plan and he stands for it yeah it
seems Hikaru really has a plan for his
bids here he's really calculating he has
good reason behind his bids what do you
think about Wesley how is what is his
strategy do you think well it feels like
Wesley would be okay with any scenario
to be honest but he will be he would
have been thinking about it more over
the last few days he will have seen that
uh that crazy bid between Magnus and
Hikaru he knows that if Hikaru is
willing to play with under nine minutes
against Magnus he's going to be willing
to play under nine minutes against
Wesley as well and Wesley just has to
weigh up in his mind is he happy with
eight and a half minutes maybe as Robert
says against Hikaru taking black or is
he going to just say okay I'll take the
white pieces I'll have a six minute
advantage and I will punish you because
he nearly did punish Nakamura in game
one of the day I do wonder if we'll see
like 8 minutes 58 it's 8 minutes 57 this
time or a few seconds lower just as the
Mind Games happen guys I'm predicting an
eight minute somewhere in the eight to
eight and a half bracket here all right
I think it's playing with fire because
we did see in game one that Wesley with
the white pieces he can get an advantage
and he almost won with equal time on the
clock so I really don't think you can go
too low but Hikaru we know his Mouse
beat he's the bullet chess champion he's
been the top rated player in the site
for so many years he will take that risk
and at the end that he can say I did it
for the fans it's gonna be so exciting
you guys uh we are waiting for the bids
to come in and we'll be back right after
this
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we're going to take a twitch break if
you're not a subscriber if you are a
subscriber while we're building up to
the big Armageddon
[Music]
still waiting for the bids to come in
from Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so what
will be their bids for the Armageddon to
decide the losers final and if you go
through to face Magnus Carlsen and
tomorrow's Grand Final while we wait
we're gonna hear uh from some of the top
players in the world before the
tournament started we met them in bike
on sale where they were playing the
total steel tournament and asked them
who they think will be the top players
in the Champions chess tour this season
if I can ask you to write how you think
the top five overall standings in
Champions Chester will look like this
season is alireza playing or is it was
into fashion now should I put myself
yeah okay
[Music]
okay I'll go with Magnus okay first one
is a long name
my mother is watching us I have to be
careful
you know what I can be confident no I
can put my name
you know I just beaten Magnus here and I
can say so I'm returning my favor there
returning a favor to good old friend
so you have Nakamura on top what is that
yeah he's just been like winning all his
events whenever I see him play he wins
so he's probably gonna take this one as
well um dink has bad internet so he he
is left out
I just put myself in the middle
yeah your handwriting is very nice
that's all that's your only bet yeah
[Music]
Magnus Carlsen is super confident uh his
only bet myself on the tourist standings
2023 he will play the grand final
tomorrow and he will play against either
Wesley so or Hikaru Nakamura they are
getting ready for Armageddon in the
losers final we are waiting for their
bids to come in
and just to remind everyone Robert what
are the regulations for the Armageddon
especially the bidding process that is
kind of new to chess a new day the
regulations have not changed so the
players have a base time of 15 minutes
you bid as low as you want and the
player with the lower bin gets to choose
their color they typically choose the
black pieces and they start with that
amount of time so if I bid eight minutes
and you bid 10 I get the eight minutes
the black pieces that I'll choose and I
get draw on so if you do not win you do
not go on so that's where the rub is you
need to win with the white pieces yeah
and yeah yesterday we saw where Magnus
go as low as 8 minutes and 58 seconds
Hikaru went as low as 8 minutes and 50.
nine seconds and that was low you guys
thought that was very low that is almost
on the limit on how low you can go well
I don't know how good they are at limbo
but it does seem like they're willing to
play with fire in terms of the clock I
think hikara being so Speedy he's okay
with it Wesley I can't see him going
that low on time against someone like a
car Nakamura do you think Hikaru will go
lower than he did yesterday though David
I think so as Robert said for the memes
for the fans for the entertainment but
also for his chances I do believe having
black just the way he's been playing is
a big bonus it means that he can react
this goes for both players just reacting
is so much easier uh in Blitz chess in
Armageddon chests especially when your
nerves are high so whoever gets black I
think is still the favorite as long as
they have over eight eight and a half
minutes but uh either way it's going to
be exciting stuff it's going to be a
race against the clock for whoever gets
back definitely definitely
um we have some news from division three
some sevion has uh won the Grand Final
against pragnananda and is the winner of
division three sending huge
congratulations to Sam for winning that
uh here we have it some Serbian the
winner of uh the Grand Final in division
three that's been a tough fight with uh
how many players 32 players was in
division three and uh Prague an amazing
player losing in the Grand Final to Sam
the Grand Final in division one is
coming up tomorrow Magnus Carlsen is uh
waiting for either Wesley Seoul or
Hikaru Nakamura to join him in that
final it will be decided here in
Armageddon we are waiting for the bids
to come in
I'm so excited for it it's just what
will it be
we can just sit back and relax because
either ways it's going to be an
incredible final and uh I think in just
a few moments Kaia we're gonna find out
uh Hikaru Wesley thinking and I see a
smile so they know each other's bit and
it looks like Wesley might I don't know
why I get the feeling but he can't
remember the one the bed this is
probably them seeing each other's bits
that means we will get them
very shortly big smile on Wesley's face
again was there only one second in it I
don't know the answer but I'm guessing
soon I think Wesley is the happier of
the two which likely means he gets the
black pieces yeah you think so just
based on the reaction there and we will
not see a quick Berlin draw that's for
sure but either way Wesley finally has a
smile on his face after game one you
know he was having to control himself he
was upset of missing a big advantage in
the winning end game but we see Wesley
he's typically stoic he is as good as
anyone at keeping calm
yeah wow I'm impatient to find out I
can't wait I can't wait I I mean I saw
Wesley smile but it almost looked like
it was an amuse smile like just a missed
one and I felt that did Hikaru win that
win that by just a small margin is he
just laughing at how bad the situation
is right now I don't know what's going
on here the color looks really focused
like in uh business mode there he looks
determined to win and uh just taking a
last break before the game starts Wesley
needs to compose himself by the way well
main part of it is that hikara hasn't
really played a game with the white
piece against Wesley every time he gets
the first move he makes this short draw
so if he does in fact have white I need
to play for a win he needs to come up
with an opening because every time he is
set across the board from Wesley he
forces that draw that is not acceptable
in this arm again guys I think I was won
the bid I I don't know why but I'm
really getting the feeling that Hikaru
gets to pick the color it's probably a
debate in chat right now who won the bid
I want to know too we're guessing here
in the studio your speculation but uh
chat what do you think yeah I don't know
here we go okay we have the Vincent
Wesley so has been
has been DeForest
Hikaru Nakamura eight minutes and five
seconds that means Hikaru wins the bid
he chooses the black uh pieces eight
minutes and five seconds guys I also got
the time right I said between 18 and a
half and I could just feel it from
Wesley's reaction that it was a closed
bed and her car was the one which means
Hikaru is perhaps gonna start with black
now and uh Wesley with 15 minutes the
pressure is on Wesley so we'll have the
white pieces he will have to win this
game to make it to the Grand Final
Hikaru with eight minutes and five
seconds and again some things happen
what's going on Hikaru with his
signature handres yeah he doesn't look
fully composed yet Hikaru of course he's
in business mode he knows it's a race
and uh okay they're off it's all about
the mouth skills now and it's the scotch
wow something that Wesley knows a lot
about you mentioned this on the previous
days Robert something happened here
what's going on with it why he is
annoyed about something maybe he's
annoyed at facing the scotch not
something you get to see every day
Wesley so has played this even in
classical events at the elite level so
it can't be a complete surprise but
Bishop D3 here that's not something
we're used to seeing oftentimes white
pushes the C Pawn to kick the Knight out
of the center but Bishop D3 I think this
is an Armageddon surprise yeah also
Hikaru launching the first surprise
Black's night coming into the center
maybe not the uh recommended antidote
nobody black kind of creates a pin on
the E5 with the Queens a lot of vocal
tension there lots of theory of course
but both players trying to get out of
that theoretical battle now this is far
from anything we've seen uh between
these two before at least in this
tournament and both players thinking at
an early stage both out of book
seemingly at least Wesley already
burning 40 seconds on his clock normally
you just trade off pawns here get
castled but things would start
disappearing from the board over already
one set of knights have left more pawns
uh getting traded decent position for
curry you would think and David you're
absolutely right this move Bishop D3 is
something that's not very common the
move the Pawn from C2 goes to C4 hits
that Knight in the center already and
that would be Mainline Theory but
instead Wesley springing this quick
surprise but Hikaru playing quick
because he has gambled quite a bit to
get the black pieces I mean an eight
minute five second bid that is playing
with fire but why is Wesley spending so
much time here I feel like you your
clock is your biggest asset and he's
really thinking quite a long time now
his advantage on the clock will remain
it's so much time to gamble for a car
knock more almost seven minutes to start
with uh but here's a bunch of options he
can just take the pawn as he finally has
done but I think he needs to make these
moves quickly that's what hit car did so
well yesterday against Magnus it didn't
quite work out but he was playing
instantly in most turns and what Hikaru
Nakamura says usually is the best advice
play good moves quickly rather than the
perfect move slowly I think Wesley needs
to take that advice right now
Scotch this early
it's commented in the twitch chat it's
late in Norway it is a good time for
Scotch it's always a good time for
scotch and meanwhile again Wesley
hesitating pausing just get that white
king to safety Castle the king what
could be more natural it definitely
feels like the nerves or the momentous
occasion it's playing on his mind and uh
okay and that's what he was thinking
about David because this is an
interesting option he takes advantage of
the fact that Hikaru did not capture
with the bishop developing a piece or
recapture that pawn with the queen and
he is attacking that D5 Knight Black's
King is still in the center now one can
be like wait a second Hikaru can pin
that Bishop a very tempting option you
move your queen to E7 because White's
King is also in the center but that is
when Wesley says I don't care I'm going
to go Castle on the right side of the
board and now sure come on pick up my
bishop and watch out for your king in
the center rookie one pins and wins the
queen Falls and this is the the idea
that Wesley was looking at now guys he's
got a win on demand every capture on the
board is where he's going to take his
time he took his time to pick up that
pawn on D6 he took his time to go for
the most combative option with the
bishop to E4 and we see the drawback
with this move Hikaru says I'm ready for
a fight doesn't care about that pawn in
the center develops his Bishop stops
white skiing from getting to safety yeah
talking of competence this is really
really hair rating stuff already her car
retrieving the most aggressive move the
most ambitious move even though he only
needs a draw now white can win a pawn
you can capture this Pawn in the center
for free seemingly but your king will be
stuck for a long time and as long as you
can defend against threats such as this
check for black then you will have a
long-term initiative the bishop pair and
White Castle kingside so really creative
stuff and uh okay he played it after not
that much thought Hikaru so the time
Advantage slowly slipping away what do
we think of this I love it I've got to
say this last move by Hikaru I love the
move by Hikaru but I love the type of
position for Wesley's so you need
something full of life and this position
is not easy to figure out so a car made
a very interesting last move but look at
the Pawns in the center even if you
don't take it right away because that
does give black time to uh maybe give
the king a check maybe bring the Rook
towards the center and go after White's
undeveloped Camp I feel like that's a
long-term problem and for her car it's
not going to be easy to solve and I
think that's exactly what Wesley needs
to keep pieces on the board keep the
problems there and he says let me just
grab the pawn right away no issues from
Wesley so's perspective it's going all
out and I love it I love this approach
of not backing down he can't afford to
be solid in this game he picks up that
extra material Hikaru moved the Rook
attacking the pawn Wesley defends it
developing his own piece of course the
king is still stuck in the center but
not for long uh David he can look at an
idea of going long castle castle on the
other side of the board but again that
will come with its own set of dangers
yeah he's uh not just looking at it I
think he's going to go for it Tanya and
it's more out of necessity than anything
that white king is never Castle in
King's side the bishop cuts across the
board like a razor there and uh as soon
as he gets given just one more move
Wesley so he's gonna Castle on the long
side he's going to say come at me and
he's going to hope that his extra porn
he can nurse it to Victory it does look
like the white Bishop has a nice home in
the center of the board as well he'll
try and neutralize Black's dark Square
Bishop blacks Bishop pair but if he does
so he's a pawn up he's five minutes up
still on the clock big Advantage I fear
for Hikaru now yeah it's a really nice
move Bishop E3 because the black dark
Squad would like to slide one square
forward in the diagonal to go after the
Knight but the problem is the white
Bishop will slide in its path off for a
trade trades do not help black in this
position so Bishop F6 will be met with
Bishop D4 the white king will safely
castle queenside in the near future and
I just get the sense that for Hikaru
he's worried about the fact that he's
not going to have a big attack on the
queen side when you are lacking in pawns
you have open files that's the good news
for black Rooks but if you Castle
kingside it takes a while for your f8
Rook to jump on over to the B8 square
and if that Rook did land on the Queen's
head then we'll be talking some serious
Firepower for black that's several moves
away the queen and the Rook have to get
out of the path I think it's just a
little bit too slow it's a little bit
too slow indeed and uh okay he speeds
things up by attacking that White Queen
but the White Queen will happily slide
back the bishop will sit on this nice
Central post that we've highlighted and
White's King should still feel
relatively cozy comfortable on the queen
side up to Hikaru now pressures on him I
mentioned that having black and
Armageddon it's an nice when you can
play reactive chess you could just play
quick moves you don't have to calculate
too much but he can't react anymore he's
a pawn down the onus the burden is on
him and he's down more than five minutes
now of course which doesn't help at all
okay he's activating his Queen Hikaru
nice move there very logical and for at
least one move white cannot Castle on
Queen side because watch out for that A2
pawn it will be hanging if white decides
to get his King safety uh at this point
so currently kings are still in the
center black is threatening to Castle
kingside on the very next move and white
Skin's still struggling there so there
is some compensation as long as Hikaru
can make sure that the king doesn't get
to safety yeah and uh Wesley so with a
big decision now but he does have time
in the bank this is a good point to
invest a minute or two just to try and
figure out how to get that white king to
safety as Tanya mentions and a critical
moment hikara will be looking for ways
to continue just annoying probing
against that White Queen side if the
white king does end up there and uh yeah
I've got to say this is lived up to
expectations this Armageddon game this
is a really fascinating to watch I'm
glad we're seeing a proper chess game no
more Berlin drops don't want to see that
Berlin draw ever again and it's only
just starting because look at hikaru's
clock just over five minutes Wesley has
now dipped under 10. but something
that's a problem in hikara's position is
even if he wins a pawn back his pawns
are split on the queen side so if Wesley
can trade the queens that doesn't just
simplify matters at all Wesley will have
a long-term nagging advantage and we
could see that in the next few moves I
actually think there is some potential
variations where Wesley for example
Castle's Queen side here if you play
Bishop takes A2 maybe the move Knight D5
look at the Queens they're staring at
each other and if you think you're just
going to trade Queens on D2 and we'll
enter an equal end game not so fast the
pawn on A7 it's already targeted the
Knight on D5 is super strong the pawn on
D6 is super weak and white will slide
the next Rook over the D file this is a
long-term advantage that Wesley could
win in a classical game of chess with
even time but with a car down to nearly
5 minutes on the clock you do not want
to have this ending Yeah the more I look
at it uh Robert that the stronger this
move appears just Castle Queen side bite
the bullet you have to be very brave you
have to calculate things correctly but
if you can get away with it meeting this
Pawn capture with the night jump then
you've got to go for it you might not
give get given another opportunity to
Castle that side uh it is very brave I
do wonder what happens if black keeps
the Queens on for example all you need
to do is move this bishop out the way
and then dive in with the queen to A1
this would be Checkmate so it's very
risky but uh if you can get away with it
you should do it now and uh Wesley is
still thinking suddenly only a three
minute advantage
time is ticking and Hikaru will be
gaining in confidence every second that
ticks away yep he uh we'll be in the
Grand Final with a draw in this game
Hikaru Nakamura five minutes and 19
seconds left on the clock no increment
in Armageddon Wesley Zoe has to win this
game and his clock is ticking now down
to eight minutes is he spending too much
time absolutely I think he's taking way
too much time because he needs to keep
the pressure live on the clock he has to
take a decision one way or the other
whether he decides to give up that pawn
and go for the lines that David and
Robert have been mentioning or make
another move but it's also hard to come
up with an alternative here you guys
have been talking about bringing the
dark Square Bishop to the center of the
board and I think that's another idea
that Wesley is looking at just shifting
this Bishop from E3 to D4 eyeing that
pawn on the king side uh the G7 Pawn but
whatever Wesley does he has to do it
quick he can't lose his time Advantage
here yeah let's see what stockfish
suggests uh potentially just how wide is
the margin for error here for white uh
how much can you go wrong but still keep
it within manageable bounds and okay wow
it did suggest pawns A3 stockfish the
best move giving over one point
Advantage for white simply because
White's one Pawn up and Wesley does
eventually find the best move but it did
come at the cost of nearly five minutes
on the clock long think and now
stockfish saying okay black has a bunch
of moves maybe the best is to push black
Central Pawn forward these guys are so
good they keep playing the best move but
uh is it enough it still thinks
stockfish that white has the advantage
and uh is now the time to Castle Queen
inside it looks just as risky as before
I've got to say but uh the computer says
yes you can get away with it black has
ideas of sacrificing pieces opening up
the position around the white king pawns
will be vulnerable on that left side but
uh he's got to calculate he's got to
decide quick Wesley so dude I have to
show an absolutely crazy line while you
were talking I was thinking well this
works or not and I think it does if you
go long Castle
guess what what what's on my mind right
now the fact that you say it's crazy
means it's a cool sacrifice it is a cool
sacrifice but it is a queen sacrifice
unless you a look at this can Queen A3
be a reality because if you pick up the
queen I give a check you side stuff with
the king I give another check with my
Rook I've got three pieces in the attack
I still don't see a mate but I think
we're getting closer King to A1 is the
only move I jump in with my Bishop give
another check you got only one square
left I pick up that Knight
you don't need to Checkmate Tanya you
only need the drawers black so you can
keep repeating moves you can keep
checking the white King For Eternity no
way the white king can hide from the
rook and the combined might of the
bishop I'm so disappointed it's not a
mate though wow yeah I mean it might be
who knows but Hikaru won't even look for
a mate he'll take the draw and get out
of here and that variation was scary
enough for Wesley so to retreat his
Knight but that's a really sad move to
play Not only have you put the Knight on
a terrible square but you've also got in
the way of your idea of Castle in
queenside and at least he's gaining a
Tempo however with the queen trade
threat and I have called Wesley so
karpovian what he's trying to do is move
his Bishop to the D4 Square then break
his Knight that was on C3 up to the E3
Square get that pesky Bishop out of C4
and the 93 protects C2 so you are more
likely to Castle queenside because
you're Bishop on D4 protects the B2 Pawn
the Knight protects the C2 Pawn I feel
like Wesley has done some really nice
maneuvering here but a car reacting very
quickly as well playing for the attack
yeah playing for the attack so now these
black bishops have really uh getting
their money's worth they're really doing
a good job this is a nasty pin but if
Wesley gets a move or two to shuffle
into the corner he'll feel very very
safe now and uh okay Hikaru has that
luxury it's only one minute in it can he
whip up an attack can he get those black
Rooks active big questions here to
answer for both sides this one could go
either way on the board on the clock
still Advantage Wesley but not by much
anymore he does Shuffle into the corner
now that white king is in safety and
white does have that extra pawn and that
beautiful Bishop on D4 really not only
defending his own the queen side the a
long Castle but also eyeing black skin
on G7 gives Wesley the hope to launch a
king side attack and that's what he's
done and Hikaru taking this opportunity
to at least go in for an opposite color
Bishop position now if pieces do end up
getting traded it can very well end in a
draw as the Bishops are not of the same
color and those positions are super
famous for uh you know even with action
material often just being a job but I'm
expecting Wesley to keep all the pieces
on the board try and create an attack on
hikaru's King because that's where the
chance is White's Bishop cannot be
challenged and that's the key your queen
jumps onto G5 you hit that pawn on G7
you're already threatening a mate in
this position Wesley looking for an
attack yeah and Hikaru looking very
proud of himself nodding his head there
this last move a very clever one I
really like it just putting his Pawn on
F6 just neutralizing any threats that
the white Bishop can create against the
black king once those threats have been
neutralized Hikaru can go about the job
of just trading off the Rooks trading
off the Queens there we go one set of
Rooks have Potter from the board if the
Rooks and queens disappear very likely
to be a drawer but uh obviously color
Bishops only one good thing in Wesley's
back pocket he's up a pawn and where is
that pawn it currently sits on B2 so at
some point he's gonna pushed that pawn
to B3 and spring free a pass Pawn
opposite colored Bishop end games with
just bishop and pawns known for their
tendency to be a draw however if you can
get an outside pass Pawn you distract
Black's pieces they have to deal with
that and then you can focus on the other
side of the board so Wesley he is
slightly better he is up a pawn he's
also still ahead but almost a minute on
the clock but this is where his car is
at his best he plays these moves so fast
he finds the strategies I just think
it's really truly difficult even if the
time had an hour on the clock for each
wow and now Hikaru hits two pawns there
was the h-bound hanging and the g the
only way to defend it is what Wesley has
played the queen jumps further and now
he's threatening background threat so
don't get greedy with the queen Wesley
if he starts approaching the queen Side
Pawn it can very well end in disaster
with a check on the back rank he falls
back first eyeing the H5 Pawn instead
and now big decision guys does black
trade off the Queens it's very committal
you can bring the black queen down to F1
on the first rank that's a pin just like
Wesley missed actually in the previous
game you've lost the trade of Queens
it's opposite color Bishops but then as
Robert mentions the white porn start
running Hikaru says no can't allow the
white pawns to move and this is a really
nice Square for the black queen she's
always centralizing is good but she's
eyeing up those white pawns on the
diagonal and uh very very difficult for
Wesley to actually make progress he can
move his Bishop around but the white
king not entirely safe I feel like
Hikaru is playing extremely well right
now yeah and it's hard for Wesley to
make any Headway still a minute in it
but uh okay second time we've seen this
position now Wesley can't repeat he
can't go for the draw and it's feels
like black spaces are so active right
now the queen and the bishop and as long
as they stay alive Hikaru creates his
chances and not trading the Queens a
great idea but I also like what Wesley's
doing he's bringing the third piece into
the game it happens to be the king and
we might see the King march up the board
all the way starting to attack the ace
the A4 Pawn Yeah and her car is
terrified of a potential King match by
white he drops the black queen here we
go come on Wesley so bring that King
forward ask those questions and if
you're Hikaru you're panicking right now
because that white king is going to
support the advance of the that white
poor majority on the queen side yeah the
queen trade will not end in a draw we
keep talking about this opposite called
the bishop usually means High chances
for the draw not here with white king
very active and there goes the bee Pawn
now your spring for your password do not
take it that's why car brings his Bishop
back he does not want to allow connected
past pawns but look at Wesley so inching
in with the queen Nexus King is coming
up to B4 he is kicking Black's pieces
back and I feel like he has great
winning chances uh was going to say yes
Hikaru come on bring the black king
forward bring the black king forward on
the king side but he's just waiting now
but the waiting game is not going to
help too much suddenly you're getting
overwhelmed on this queen side it's
three pieces against two Black's King is
just a innocent bystander here and does
Wesley take another Pawn take it and the
car was shaking his head he hates his
position he hates what he's trying to
defend otherwise he just thought back
with the King now remember there's no
increment here so repetition makes no
sense I'm surprised he didn't pick up
that a second free for free he's going
backwards that's the wrong direction the
white king is super safe here yes but it
was doing such a good job leading from
the front but the time Wesley so is an
experienced bullet player we know how
good it Karo is Wesley he's no slouch
either so he's using the clock as a
weapon because if they're both spending
a few seconds per turn that's good news
for Wesley because at some point Hikaru
may not be able to find the correct
continuation with just under a minute on
his clock which is where we're heading
yeah that's actually very clever that's
a really relevant Point uh Robert you're
just going to maneuver on the dark
squares you can pretty much pre-move the
next few turns for Wesley and uh only
when you reach that kind of 40 50 move
Mark then you push upon then you commit
and then the counter starts to Fresh
play on that 50 move rule don't
necessarily need to rush to make any
progress and oh wow another offer of a
trade of Queens this is confident stuff
from Wesley I would not be 100 confident
this is when uh the winning this this uh
queenless end game but he's asking that
question look how her car is burning
time having to decide Queen trade or no
Queen trade and the state is quite
maintained the clocks are ticking I
wrestlers played amazing chess right now
every move placing a piece on the dark
Square just keeping up the pressure
offering a queen trade at the right time
he does it again hikarus made up his
mind that no matter what he's not going
into an end game here and it's Wesley
slowly and subtly improving his peace
position the queen has landed on D6 a G4
break in the air so dangerous on both
sides now but F3 that was not timed
correctly by Wesley because look at the
black queen it's ready to jump into the
board if that pawn captures back on B3
so that was an inopportune moment for
Wes so you take with this King which is
not what you want you want connected
pawns and hit cards immediately going
for the attack on the C2 Pawn he's
jumping and you don't have time to pick
up the D5 Pawn the Ft Pawn that you
pointed out badly timed is also hanging
yeah suddenly it's turned around we saw
Hikaru do his uh trademark head Bob
there he knows that he's fought back and
now he could just give a couple of
checks where's this white king gonna
hide the black queen can come back where
she came from eye up some of those weak
white pawns on the king side and at
first he activates his King I love to
see it King of the Hill here both Kings
advancing but uh still the clock the
biggest Factor 40 seconds in it now
Wesley retreating he's lost control
suddenly not so easy look how the black
queen is just causing a nuisance from
behind here so many weaknesses in
Wesley's camp and the King's got nowhere
to hide the white king which looked
absolutely safe is now just running
Helter Skelter because there is no safe
Square from checks black meanwhile has
sidestep any threats along that pin that
it was there and King G6 is
needs just a draw and it looks like
Wesley might have missed a huge
opportunity his head Wesley now it's
only 15 seconds in it but he needs to be
Shameless that's the problem that Wesley
is having right now he needs to go for
the flag it may be called dirty it's
whatever go for the time and now he's
doing it but he's giving up some pawns
and his car is really not down the clock
at all it's a pure bullet game at this
point I mean a little over a minute per
side and there are no problems for black
anymore dermak is asking in the twitch
chat can Wesley simply flag Hikaru not
anymore yeah at this point it's Hikaru
trying to flag Wesley it's basically
level on the clock and actually if
anything hikaru's position is easier to
play look at this he's just gobbling up
horns black has the more dangerous
possible and Black's H Pawn is going to
start running any moment Wesley on the
defensive on the board and now not in
charge on the clock anymore I would pick
black here I've got to say and you can
see it in his body language he knows it
and Wesley they're shaking his head he's
attacking the bishop Hikaru gives a
check first the King moves forward that
H5 Pawn is going to be a big distraction
and now he says I'm ready for an end
game because he's got a passer of his
own the queen turns a force there's no
way that white can avoid it without just
losing the game on the spot that's why
hikara's Road of slaves were in the end
game white has these outside pass pawns
but look at Black's H Pawn that one is
running up the board very fast it's
helped out it's gonna be escorted by the
black king and the other pawns this is
just easy for a car right now and he's
even ahead on time right he doesn't have
any problems whatsoever yeah looks like
black is completely winning the race
even without Black's three pawns this is
still actually a draw so uh Hikaru he
knows he's got this in the bag he's
smiling he's got a Time advantage and he
clinches his fist Wesley resigns fist
bump wow it's uh over Hikaru Nakamura
makes it through to the Grand Final he
will face off against Magnus Carlsen
tomorrow again winning here in
Armageddon look at that t-car Nakamura
what a beastieous and uh this
four months incredible is he Frozen or I
think he was frozen there but we'll see
the fist bump the fist pump any moment
now Wesley meanwhile shaking his head he
knows this it was a missed opportunity
he had a pawn Advantage he had a few
minutes Advantage but the car too good
yeah how impressed are you Robert with
Hikaru Nakamura it was amazing because
he was defending accurately but I
thought Wesson was actually going to
flag Hikaru he's playing every accurate
move into one little slip and the car
doesn't hesitate he realizes a mistake
and he's able to secure an equal
position and then he's just much better
and Wesley had no choice but to tip his
King over yeah is it down to experience
from Hikaru just having done this so
many times in online chess well I don't
think Wesley's done it anytime less I
think Hikaru really believes in his
abilities when it comes to the
Armageddon which of course he's up
against Wesley is also super duper
strong in these kind of moments and it
was amazing to see Wesley create his
chances with this game with the white
pieces I think it all came down I saw
him marching up with the King and I was
like Wesley's got this he's doing all
the right things he realized the queen
trade works for him but then just one
missed opportunity and we keep saying
this Kaya that Hikaru is so hard to beat
in these positions you give him one
chance to come back the guy does it
super super resilient super resourceful
and that's what saved the day for him
today yeah and he's ready for the Grand
Final we're joined by Hikaru Nakamura
big big congratulations
ah thank you yeah it was a very uh
interesting match let's put it that way
yeah and what is your take on what
happened in the end here in the
Armageddon
yeah I mean obviously after yesterday I
wanted to bid low just to ensure that I
got black
um and I did get it but I think I mean
my bid my bid was probably okay but the
opening that I played was very shaky um
not so much in that it was uh that it
wasn't playable but it was a very
double-edged position where I can win or
I can lose
um because I'm sacking a pawn and when
you're in that situation and you're down
on the clock it's really not optimal
um and I suspect I was okay at some
point
um after I sacked the pawn but with like
eight minutes you kind of have to just
go you can't really think too long and
Wesley was definitely better
um I don't know if he was ever winning I
mean it was also very tricky because
there were multiple times that I could
go into a bishops of opposite color end
game but I wasn't really sure whether
that's a draw or whether I'm losing or
what's going on so I rejected that
um and then yeah he made this one
mistake uh when he allowed me to take on
B3 with the queen to E2 chuck if he
doesn't do this I think there's still a
very good chances he wins that being
said I had my optimal setup already
where I'm guarding the pawn on A4 he
can't really push B4 C4 without the
pawns getting blockaded
um so it would have been on Wesley to to
prove it but he he had chances for sure
but one blunder was was too much how
scientific do you get when making your
bids in the Armageddon Hikaru
yeah I mean I don't think it's about
being scientific I think it's the one
Wesley and I play we're both extremely
solid I mean for the most part we played
the exact same openings with both colors
um and and so I just want to be black no
matter what I mean I thought about going
even lower than I bid I mean I thought
about going below eight but I mean at
some point you you have to feel like if
your opponent outbids you it's what it
is like you just play with the white
pieces you take the time advantage and
try to win as opposed to being like
being really really clever I mean
yesterday Magnus and I got got it down
to like sub nine minutes and actually a
funny funny tidbit is that on the um on
the first day when I played uh or the
first match against Wesley when I made
my bid the guy at chess.com when I when
I wrote like 928 I think it was he's
like are you sure it's 15 it's a 15
minute game and it was kind of funny
because obviously everyone is bidding
well below 10 now so I mean I think what
I did today was was definitely very much
on the edge I find it hard to believe
you can go much lower
um but I I found a win that's really all
that matters definitely hey guys
congratulations that was an absolute
thrilling Armageddon to watch and I have
to ask you about that first game against
Wesley the very last moment when you
moved that King to F7 what happened that
just take us through that uh that
situation
I mean the thing is initially I didn't
realize that he could trade the Queens
there was there was another variation
where I think the Queens get traded on
like E6 I win the e-pawn but he can go
like King G3 and F4 and that's winning
and so initially I didn't realize that
that that existed and I spot it but then
later as as we're getting low on time I
mean I just played King F7 because I was
sure Queen E6 was the only move I just
for some reason I just thought Queen F3
I go Queen F6 trade King takes King E5
and I'm I'm just winning so I win the
pawn but with the double pawns on the B
file it's actually losing and yeah I
think pretty much as soon as I played it
he moved instantly so I didn't quite I
didn't like quite have time for it to
register until after the draw uh
occurred but I did in that Split Second
I kind of did realize that it was a
mistake but you know it is what it is
and obviously it's a bit of a miracle
but that's how it goes when something
sorry when something like that happens
do you also think that shifts the
momentum for you in a way that Wesley
realizes he had this huge opportunity to
take a match lead but failed to do so in
that critical moment
yeah I mean of course if you miss a win
and one where there's no counter play
where you just trade into a king upon
end game which you're going to win 100
of the time I mean it's it is somewhat
devastating I mean that being said it's
very tricky too because after that I
wasn't sure if I should just make the
drawer if I should actually try to beat
him because Wesley obviously was
frustrated I could see it on his face
and and so I had a decision too but I
figured at the end of the day um you
know I'd rather flip coins and hopefully
hopefully it comes with pads more times
than it comes up tells and the Hikaru
Festival congratulations uh looking
forward to tomorrow you're playing
Magnus at least once maybe even two
matches what's your strategy going to be
like as you aim for Revenge
um you know I I don't know I I I feel
like uh the the two the two matches that
I played against Max this one and also
the the famous one back in 2020 where we
played over seven days which was also
rather fittingly uh decided by an arm
again you know I think I mean we're both
both very good players
um I mean if there's anything maybe I'll
play more with more risk because I do
have twin two matches you know for
example say we get to an Armageddon
tomorrow and I win that arm again I
still to win another match it's not as
simple as winning one match so I mean
maybe I'll take more risks it's hard to
know but uh it's always good to be in
the finals and it's always fun to play
against Magnus um you know we've played
a lot over the years and um he's the
best of the best so you want if you want
to win you have to beat the best and
that's that's how I view it yeah Hikaru
the chat has been asking this question a
lot we asked Magnus yesterday so I have
to ask you which Pokemon is your
favorite
I mean I've never I've never I've never
played Pokemon it's just not my thing so
you know I'm more of an old school guy I
played like the the OG games you know
the things like Diablo Warcraft
Starcraft like the real OG games not as
new age hippie stuff
very cool and uh well we're all looking
forward to your match against Magnus
tomorrow you're still unbeaten in the
air things monsters how happy are you
with the way you're playing
you know that that's actually an
interesting question you know more more
broadly speaking it's not not even so
much about this about about this event
but when you think about tournaments I
mean the the classic question that you
can ask top players is you know if you
play two games and you draw two games is
that better than winning a game and
losing a game and most players would say
that two draws is better
um and in a match format certainly it's
much more important to not lose games
and I just say win a game and lose the
game um so it's definitely benefited me
being very solid but at the same time I
mean the drawback is when you play and
say Swiss tournaments like the world
Blitz or the world rapid and you have to
win a lot of games you know if you draw
Too Many Games bad things happen so I'm
happy that I've gone undefeated I mean
against Wesley I've had a couple of bad
bad positions against Magnus in the
first game probably I was losing at one
moment so even though even though I
haven't lost game it hasn't been like
super solid so I'm somewhat pleased with
my play but there's definitely room for
improvement
wow we're all so excited oh it's been a
treat to watch you in this tournament so
far and tomorrow is such a big day for
all of us and for the chess fans so I
just want to look ahead a little more
with that on that with you and just in
your own words uh what do you think that
in this format what is it that Magnus
perhaps does better than you and what is
it that you do better than Magnus
I mean Magnus is uh much better getting
winning positions and converting them
that's a simple simple answer I mean I
haven't really had many opportunities I
mean I don't think I've had any real
opportunities to win win a game since uh
the first day when I played against goo
cash
um so he's very good at converting I'm
very good at defending and hanging on um
for a long time I mean those I think
that's the biggest difference between us
certainly again you know as far as the
individual match yesterday I mean Magus
had some chances third game maybe for
like a move or two I had some chances
but uh you know it came down to
Armageddon and that that's that's that's
how it goes I mean could you really say
that I was better than Wesley in either
of these matches I don't I don't know if
you could even really say that I mean I
think Wesley was just as good as me it's
just that I got black in the critical
game and he wasn't able to beat me in
either of the two matches so I think
it's I think the edges are very very
small and I mean I think we're both
great competitors and hopefully uh
hopefully tomorrow tomorrow will be fun
yeah are you enjoying this format uh
Hikaru with Dublin elimination match
format Armageddon bidding everything
going on
yeah I mean I I think uh I mean to be
truthful I have to like the format
because honestly for the stronger
players double elimination is better I
mean for someone like Wesley for example
you know after he lost maybe he was done
he's done but he had a chance to come
back had a chance to win today
um so if I'm being truthful double
elimination definitely favors the
stronger players uh because because they
have to have two bad days as opposed to
one bad day
um so I you know in general it's very
good for me uh I think for the fans
though it's also quite exciting because
when you know somebody has a bad day
like goo catch for example against me I
mean he just was completely out of form
lost two games and it's all over right
there basically
um but he has a chance to come back so I
think I think that that's helpful and
then also the fact that someone can lose
a match and win win two two matches
tomorrow to win the whole thing I I like
it I think I think it's good overall and
of course it benefits me so I mean of
course of course it's good yeah
hey girl we appreciate you talking to us
and we wish you best of luck in the
grand final tomorrow
thank you so much you guys all the best
all of us tomorrow hikara Nakamura
against Magnus Carlson tomorrow but what
a fight it was between Hikaru and Wesley
So today we're also joined by Wesley
playing two matches today now knocked
out of the air things monsters how are
you Wesley
not very good
it was a very close
that's yeah definitely what what uh what
happened there in the end in the
Armageddon
yeah I think I was just uh slower I
didn't
I didn't have good nerves in the end
like I knew I had very good chances to
win and I thought I was going to but you
know I just uh
I just played to immediately and also
like my nerves didn't keep up the
crucial moments and I was looking at my
club you know he cares clearly faster
also in the Armageddon without any
increment uh even if you get the winning
position you have to be very careful on
that flag so I was keeping an eye on
that and then uh I didn't work out and
then on move
I was trying to trade wins because I was
pretty sure that if the queenford traded
that the end game is pretty
straightforward winning when I talked
with my queen of 2016 you know it was
pretty clinical but
um
the problem with even if you get a
winning position against Ricardo who
just never gives up and take it he keeps
he keeps defending extremely well like
you know I think anyone else would have
lost that position upon down with the
opposite called Bishops but
uh Hikaru just defended extremely well
then I blundered and move uh they did
too yeah but I I think I think like when
he played Bishop B5 I think I should
just take the a pawn
before then A5
and I was regretting not playing that
like and
at least I have a path compared to
compared to the game then definitely try
to push my pawns on the king side but I
waited too long like uh I I both want to
go this F3 G4 try to attack his King but
I just played it the worst possible
moment but with two minutes with three
minutes on the clock it's not a no
increment it's not so so easy for for
your nerves yeah we did see uh some big
smiles on your face when the bids came
in what was your reaction to her going
as low as eight minutes and five seconds
yeah that was pretty shocking I
because I think it's insane to go that
low like I we we had this building Wars
starting last year for the global Chess
Championship and back then players were
beating extremely high like 12 minutes
and against Jefferson I bid 11 minutes
and it's just insane that anyone would
go it but it depends eight minutes and
eight minutes and five yeah
yeah I mean it's totally insane because
if you think about it normal Armageddon
is five minutes for white and four four
black
so then if white has 10 minutes then
it's eight minutes like in stop hunger I
think it's 10 breath of seven
but and so you think that I get 15
minutes you need at least uh nine
minutes or nine and a half but
or even 10 minutes but it's just totally
insane that anyone would go that low
like I was pretty sure that I would get
the black Pieces by beating 829 and I'm
not sure if it's a good idea but I
wanted to try black
for the last game and see how it goes
but I mean if you bid eight minutes then
you're clearly gonna win like I'm not
sure it's a it's a great idea honestly
uh but uh
uh you know hiker was pretty confident
to do that like
eight minutes is just so little time
like your opponent can basically try to
try to flag you as long as uh he gets a
game and yeah I've flown fear compared
to the equal strength so that's why I'm
very happy when I won the extra pawn and
in the opening I think uh it's funny
Hikaru just played Knight D5 clearly I
think he makes a piss opening line like
he was just playing quickly so it's
that's totally insane of course but I
mean big congratulations to uh Hikaru
for winning twice against me and uh you
know I I think that they had I was
playing well like I had very good
chances to to win this match uh but my
nerves wasn't able to keep up with with
my play yeah Wesley I feel guilty
bringing this up now but we did see a
big reaction uh from Hikaru after game
one of your match uh on the final move
if you checked afterwards did you
realize that there was a win there just
on the final move
uh yeah I didn't realize that the final
move was winning but I was winning
before that
uh so
you know if we're happy to play D5 also
on move 32 hope 33
uh he made the blunder with King H7 when
he should like win F4 and black probably
hold the door but when you play King H7
uh instead of trading Rooks I could just
play Rook E6
and it's basically completely winning
for white it's like plus four
um but also on move um 36.
uh if you when you play G5 which was a
blunder like I should just play Queen E6
and I was thinking about this move like
Queen E6
and if it doesn't trade Queen if you
play Queen f8 then there's Queen G6 and
he's he loses his king size Pawns
because his King is tough meanwhile if
he trades wins with takes takes King G7
then the pawn end game is Just winning
after F4
or or even I guess it King G2 and F4 so
I was spending some time thinking about
Queen E6
but unfortunately I didn't play that if
I was winning at some point at certain
points like more than once
um
so yeah things would have been much
different
but that's a Pity yeah but you've had a
huge uh tournament Wesley almost
unbeaten I can see you're sitting inside
with a jacket it's a very cold in
Minnesota where you are right now
yeah I guess I guess uh
well it's getting warmer I guess
you have superstitious I mean
uh wearing the same jacket since day one
like maybe I should change to a better
jacket but I didn't want to change
anything and I didn't think I'd reached
this this far the tournament so uh
it's nice and uh
and you know we're we're leaving
tomorrow so I thought I wouldn't change
anything but uh
lucky jacket
it's been super enjoyable to watch you
play here and there things monsters and
uh we're super excited because we
definitely will see you in division one
also in the next event
yeah I mean that was my main plan for
today to at least qualify for
tomorrow because it would be nice to
meet the curb at the same time then I
play Magnus tomorrow and
uh maybe he has a better chance than
than me and uh yeah again yeah we
congratulations to Hikaru with a nice
defense and uh hopefully he he
feels uh better regarding his family
issues uh right now
well Wesley thank you so much for all
the entertainment and uh we'll see you
again in the next event thank you also
for joining us
yeah I'm very excited to join now I'm
going to have to prepare for classical
tournaments thank you guys thank you so
much Wesley
it takes third place Wesley so in the
air things Monsters uh what a player
losing only one game it's been
incredible for Wesley so as well he was
in fantastic form and the way he played
the games he had the advantages on the
board against the car knock more but he
just couldn't put him away and he's so
humble he has so much respect for his
opponent he's always trying to be
objective and I just wonder if he lost
that objectivity for a second down the
stretch of that Armageddon game maybe he
could have flagged takaru he just had to
throw away the actual evaluation
function and just focus on the clock
yeah
all right let's take a look at the
bracket we only have one day and one
potentially two matches left in the air
things monsters Magnus Carlsen he won
the winners final yesterday against
Hikaru Nakamura so it's been a day off
today for Magnus Carlsen he will play in
the grand final tomorrow to face now
Hikaru Nakamura another big match
between these two it's gonna be best out
of four rapid games with
Armageddon tie breaks if they are tied
if Hikaru Nakamura wins that match then
the Grand Final will go to a reset
because that means Magnus calls will
also have lost a match and the Grand
Final will be decided with a two game
match also again with Armageddon tie
breaks if they are tied what's your
expectations for that David will we see
Magnus win it in the first match or will
we see Hikaru Nakamura get his revenge
I'm not sure what to expect Kyle but I
can't wait just the thought of one match
between them is Juicy enough we already
had that a couple of days ago we're
gonna get a second match with them a
third match would be a charity uh and
the icing on the cake so yeah I just
want a full-blooded fight in that one
and may the best man win yeah
potentially they're gonna play six rapid
games and two Armageddon games tomorrow
Tonya it's gonna be a long day probably
and that must be exhausting coming up
Madness is to make sure he doesn't have
any late nights tonight so that's one
thing and you're absolutely right energy
is going to be absolutely key and I
think this is a dream final this is a
this is an absolute dream final for us
for chess fans everywhere the one thing
that when I look back at their first
match in this event is that perhaps if
Hikaru does get the chance with the
white pieces he needs to make the most
of it the strategy of going for an
Armageddon
might work with everyone Under the Sun
but might not be the best bet against
Magnus Carlsen if you've got the white
pieces you need to make the most of it
definitely
the Grand Final in division one is
coming up tomorrow the Grand Final in
division two is also coming up tomorrow
we actually don't know who's going to
play in that yet the only player we know
definitely will play there is Fabiano
cariana he has won the winners final
today but the losers bracket is still
going on in division two to decide who
will face
Carolina tomorrow
in the grand the final in division two
and in division three we already have a
winner the Grand Final was played today
and young Sam Savion is the winner of
bad TV
in the Grand Final
what a day what a day it's been we have
one more day in the air things monsters
and today as well we've had a very cool
puzzle Ivanka it's time to reveal the
answer to the puzzle yeah it was a short
and sweet one but it was cute I would
say it's from a study from 1964 by afan
Sega and uh
okay the whole idea is that you know
white is in Dire Straits the black porn
is going to promote and there's only one
path to Salvation and also to Victory
and that's just to push the seaport one
square forward trap the king and uh well
people could be asking well what is that
porn just not promote and here comes the
killer thing the night walk jump to the
D6 square and suddenly like a bolt from
the blue you'll realize that the king is
actually trapped now there's one final
trick in this position to see and that
is black could play Queen takes Pawn
but this is actually no good because of
night to B7 check and uh suddenly the
queen can be taken the King has to step
away horn takes Queen and that is it the
Knight can step forward and also defend
the bit Pawn on e4 and that is it
beautiful
but simple and those are the puzzles
that I like
definitely beautiful puzzle and uh we
did ask you guys to uh share your
answers on social media and we would
actually pick a winner to get a very
cool prize today Ivanka what is the
price it is a six months a diamond
membership of chess.com and I have to
say this winner has a very cool name
I'm excited to hear it okay it's gobble
squat King oh no this is Joe I'm sorry
John solo oh no
actually uh C3 and there he gives
absolutely every single variation
fantastic wow good job John solo you are
the winner and uh we'll get a very cool
prize we also have a winner uh in our
selfie competition you guys have been so
cool sharing your selfies on Twitter
using the hashtag chess Champs
Carol the seaport is the winner what a
nice uh selfie oops I played the bomb
Cloud again
might need an air things device to
improve my chest well you're getting one
and everything's device signed by Magnus
Carlsen is coming for you and the five
the Grand Final in the air things
monsters is coming up tomorrow it's
gonna be between the two giants in
online chess minus Carlsen and Hikaru
Nakamura who do you think will win it
now why do I
I am just ready for the match I can't
wait for it and I think it was a little
heartbreaking today for Wesley you know
he had his chances he played a brilliant
Armageddon but tomorrow is the big day
we'll have our champion tomorrow and
like I said Kaya this is really a dream
final and I'm so excited for it hard to
pick a favorite we've seen it in this
format Anything Can Happen bring in the
popcorn yeah David
um I'll say Hikari just because it feels
like he can hit at another level and I
can't wait to see him try tomorrow nice
and Robert I think David is just taking
that answer because he knows what I was
gonna say it has to say Magnus Carlsen
he has two lives so he's the heavy
favorite uh he would be the favorite
even if he just had one but with two
lives of course it's Magnus Carlsen oh
it's gonna be a super exciting first
Grand Final in the 2023 Champions chess
tour the Grand Final is coming up
tomorrow between those two giants so
join us for all the action we could
potentially have two armageddons coming
up tomorrow we'll see you then have a
good night or date wherever you are in
the world in the meantime bye
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you